donc l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions au Gouvernement la première
d'entre elles va être posée par Monsieur
Sébastien Chenu pour le rassemblement
national
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'économie des finances et de la
désindustrialisation parce que nous
sommes le Parti de la France qui
travaille de la France qui aimerait
travailler de la France qui a travaillé
j'étais ce matin aux côtés des ouvriers
de Val d'une dans le Nord j'étais avec
eux je tiens à les remercier ses
ouvriers qui voient défiler d'ailleurs
tous ceux qui pendant des années ont
ruiné l'industrie de notre pays et qui
viennent parfois même leur donner des
cours d'écologie j'étais avec eux parce
que valdune pourrait fermer c'est le
dernier fabricant français de roues de
train dont l'unique actionnaire chinois
déclaré kilométrait plus un centime dans
la société valdune c'est 336 emplois
dans le Nord à tri Saint Léger et alors
que le savoir-faire la productivité les
compétences la qualité du travail est
reconnue de tous et bien aujourd'hui
cette entreprise est menacée
l'investisseur chinois a obtenu ce qu'il
voulait les brevets le savoir-faire la
technologie aujourd'hui elle est prêt à
plier bagages laissant les ouvriers les
employés dans le désarroi ce pillage des
compétences françaises cette incapacité
à contraindre une entreprise française
comme la SNCF a passé des commandes
publiques pour les routes train à une
entreprise française en dit long sur
l'abandon de nos fleurons industriels en
dit long sur votre soumission en 2021
j'avais déjà alerté par écrit le
ministre de l'économie des finances et
de la désindustrialisation je n'ai
jamais eu de réponse le mépris la
désinvolture monsieur le ministre
aujourd'hui qu'elle sort réservez-vous à
valdune à ces salariés qu'attendez-vous
pour appliquer la préférence nationale
de la commande publique comme Marine Le
Pen le suggérait pour protéger notre
industrie pour agir concrètement via la
BPI puisque vous aviez vous avez des
leviers en main en 2022 vous avez
autorisé plus de 130 achats
d'entreprises sensibles par des
étrangers quand allez-vous vous occuper
enfin de l'industrie française
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Roland Lescure ministre délégué
chargé de l'Industrie
madame la Présidente de mesdames
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
Chenou comme comme toujours vous
simplifier vous instrumentalisez vos
caricaturez la réindustrialisation de la
France elle a commencé il y a 6 ans
c'est pas grâce à vous c'est grâce à
cette majorité et vous savez quoi un
Vasso poursuivre
en ce qui concerne en ce qui concerne
l'entreprise valdune vous le savez elle
a été reprise par un actionnaire chinois
il y a maintenant une dizaine d'années
en 2014 cette actionnaire chinois
contrairement à ce que vous dites à
réinvesti dans son entreprise plus de
100 millions d'euros et malgré ses
réinvestissements et des pertes
afférentes
l'entreprise n'a pas réussi à gagner des
parts de marché à l'international vous
le savez sans doute puisque vous suivez
cette entreprise de prêt valdune c'est
aujourd'hui une capacité de production
de 100000 roues par an la SNCF si elle
achète toutes ces routes valdune en
achèterait 30 à 40000 maximum on a un
défi de compétitivité pour ce site nous
l'avons
identifié puisque nous n'avons pas
attendu que vous intéressiez à cette
entreprise pour la regarder de près nous
avons convoqué la direction et
l'actionnaire depuis un an nous avons
mis en place une étude indépendante qui
montre qu'aujourd'hui on a deux défis un
outil de production extrêmement ancien
la forge date de 1950 et un défi de
capacité de production depuis vendredi à
l'occasion d'un CE se exceptionnelle
nous avons plus d'informations sur
malheureusement le désengagement annoncé
par l'actionnaire nous allons de ce fait
les convoquer à nouveau ils seront à
Bercy demain nous allons recevoir les
organisations syndicales de manière à
voir comment accompagner cette
entreprise vers la voie sans doute d'une
reprise en tout cas nous ferons tout
pour je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre monsieur le ministre on n'a pas
besoin d'une réponse de chat GPT on a
besoin d'action bougez-vous
monsieur le ministre
monsieur Chenu
vos bonbons vous pouvez vous les garder
ce gouvernement depuis six ans il a créé
plus d'emplois industriels que vous
n'entrerez jamais il a réindustrialisé
il a recréé des entreprises y compris
dans le Nord sur lequel vous vous
nourrissez la désindustriation depuis 50
ans c'est terminé nous allons continuer
à agir vous allez continuer à parler
merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Philippe
Gosselin pour le gonflet républicain
s'adresse la première ministre depuis
des mois une crise sans précédent du
logement s'annonçait elle est là madame
la Première ministre tous les acteurs le
disent les marchés des transactions
immobilières et je les celui des
locations est asphyxié le mal logement
s'aggrave en France depuis 6 ans il
manque au moins 100 000 logements en
France cela touche tous les territoires
et tous les types de logements y compris
le logement social on est en manque
cruel alors bien sûr les causes sont
multiples mais elles se cumulent les
doses d'intérêts ont augmenté les
crédits se sont resserrés et les banques
sont devenues extrêmement frileuses le
foncier se fait rare ce sont les
blocages des projets en jaune en zone et
rainues les zones rurales qui sont les
plus touchées mais c'est aussi les pays
lui qui n'avancent pas et que dire des
fameuses
ânes ce 0 artificialisation nette qui de
plus de plus devient des aime le 0 ou
zone emmerdement maximal oui on en est
là c'est aussi la question dont la
fiabilité de plus en plus en cause avec
des mesures nouvelles qui leur sont
adossés avec les passoires énergétiques
qui retirent du marché des dizaines de
milliers de logements par an dans les
mois et les années qui viennent c'est
encore des difficultés avec ma prime
rénove avec des particuliers des
entreprises qui attendent des paiements
souvent aléatoires et réduits n'en jetez
plus la coupe est pleine et il paraît
que l'Europe va en rajouter une couche
la crise du logement elle est bien là
alors tout cela entretient un fort
ressentiment social nos concitoyens n'en
peuvent plus le président de la
République au début de son premier
mandat avait annoncé un choc sur l'offre
de logements il est là le choc mais pas
dans le sens qui était souhaité alors
madame la Première ministre que
comptez-vous faire pour soutenir le
logement aider nos concitoyens qui en
ont tant besoin
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Olivier Klein
ministre délégué chargé de la ville et
du logement
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Philippe Gosselin le gouvernement agit
le gouvernement agit depuis 6 ans pour
le logement vous avez commencé en
parlant du mal logement lancer des 2018
le plan logement d'abord a permis à
440000 personnes ne quitter la rue et
d'entrer dans un dans un foyer le
logement c'est aussi la rénovation
thermique vous l'avez rappelé c'est 1,5
millions de chantiers qui ont pu voir le
jour c'est l'économie d'une ville
équivalente à la ville de Lyon le
gouvernement agit pour protéger les
Français en mettant en place tous les
boucliers tarifaires possibles sur le
gaz sur l'électricité qu'on soit chauffé
de manière individuelle ou de manière
collective ensuite oui il y a des
difficultés oui monsieur vous savez très
bien que le logement c'est une
responsabilité
expérimentée il faut mobiliser les mers
il faut mobiliser les mers pour leur
donner envie de construire absolument
ils ont les capacités de construire et
nous le c'est le sens du CNR que nous
avons lancé et il est dans les
conclusions seront données très
prochainement sur la crise actuelle nous
travaillons avec l'ensemble de du monde
du logement privé ou public pour
préparer une relance une relance à
travers une action de la Caisse des
dépôts et conciliation une relance à
travers un soutien au prêt à taux zéro
qui est un moyen pour nos concitoyens le
plus fragiles d'avoir accès à la
propriété une relance à travers le le
contrat de confiance avec les bailleurs
sociaux comme la première ministre
l'indiquée dans sa feuille de route ce
document sera signé avant l'automne dans
le cadre du congrès de l'USH et nous
avons travaillé nous continuerons à
travailler sur cette crise du logement
je vous remercie je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre monsieur Gosselin
merci madame la ministre le gouvernement
est dans le dans le déni complet vous
nous dites que vous avez fait beaucoup
de choses mais beaucoup restent à faire
et pour le moment on attend des mesures
concrètes vous savez si vous voulez
éviter d'avoir des casseroles au delà
des cuisines des casseroles ailleurs et
bien il va falloir prendre ce dossier à
bras le corps monsieur le ministre il y
a de vrais vrais questions sur le
logement et les maires ne peuvent pas
tout faire il y a les ânes qui les
empêchent de construire
la parole est à Monsieur le Ministre et
madame la Présidente vous savez quand on
veut faire le Tartuffe on peut faire le
Tartuffe le zanne le zanne Lausanne est
une Lausanne est un moyen de protéger
notre environnement et c'est un alibi
qui est aujourd'hui utilisé par trop
grand monde pour ne pas réaliser du
logement
les PLU les PLU sont à la disposition
des élus locaux et doivent continuer à
travailler je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre
mes chers collègues un peu de silence la
parole est uniquement au président
Bourlens pour le groupe démocrate
rassurez-vous ce sera plus calme madame
royaume ministre madame le ministre mes
chers collègues nous célébrons
aujourd'hui l'appel à la construction
d'une Europe unie l'ensilia 73 ans par
Robert Schuman
le groupe modèle se garderait de manquer
à ce rendez-vous du souvenir et de
l'avenir
l'Europe c'est aujourd'hui deux choses
deux choses essentielles la paix pour
vivre ensemble et la synergie pour vivre
libre
les Français aiment l'Europe quand ils
regardent le passé parce qu'elle a su
mettre un terme au cauchemar de la
guerre éternelle qui a empoisonné leur
histoire les Français aiment l'Europe
quand ils regardent l'avenir car ils
savent que seuls l'union fait la force
mais cet avenir est inédit j'oserait
dire
révolutionnaire au cours des 20
dernières années l'Europe est confort a
été confronté dans l'ordre géopolitique
écologique démographique technologique
écologique et démocratique a six défis
majeurs elle n'y a répondu que de façon
partielle malgré les appels répétés du
président de la République dans la
foulée de son discours de la Sorbonne
les Européens sont agglamment
globalement incapables de répondre aux
trois questions qui déterminent les
réponses qui quoi comment
qui sont les Européens c'est la question
l'identité commune quoi que voulons-nous
faire ensemble et que l'on nous
continuer de faire séparément comment
c'est la question d'un modèle
institutionnel contesté mais il
remplaçable on ne bâtira pas l'Europe de
demain sur le détricotage de l'Europe
d'hier nos concitoyens retrouveront foi
dans le projet commun à la condition de
se voir offrir simultanément une vision
claire et des actions fortes nous devons
tenir ensemble les deux bouts de la
chaîne nous avons besoin d'un CAP et
d'un calendrier un cap pour choisir un
calendrier pour agir que le gouvernement
entendit faire pour offrir l'un et
l'autre aux électeurs européens de l'an
prochain merci monsieur le président la
parole est à madame la Première ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
président Jean-Louis bourlange vous
l'avez dit nous traversons une période
de crise multi par le retour de la
guerre sur notre continent par la
volonté d'affirmation des
superpuissances et la nécessité de
renforcer notre indépendance énergétique
industrielle alimentaire et stratégiques
face à ces défis pour peser et bâtir
notre souveraineté plus que jamais la
solution passe par l'Union européenne
bien sûr les partisans du repli sur soi
et les populistes des deux bords M a
accablé l'Europe l'Europe et leur bouc
émissaire commode et serait la cause de
tous leurs mots ils oublient que c'est
l'Europe qui a permis une relance
majeure de l'économie après le covid que
c'est l'Europe qui nous permet
d'apporter une réponse ferme et résolue
face à l'agression russe en Ukraine que
c'est l'Europe qui nous permet d'avoir
une ambition climatique puissante et
coordonnée que c'est l'Europe qui permet
de défendre notre souveraineté
alimentaire et nos agriculteurs que
c'est l'Europe qui nous permet de
soutenir notre économie face au
subventions étrangères sources de
concurrence déloyale
l'Union européenne devient une puissance
et nous pouvons être fiers du chemin
parcouru car sous l'égide du président
de la République la France prend toute
sa part dans ce combat mesdames et
messieurs les députés je ne dis pas que
l'Europe est parfaite et les défis qui
nous attendent sont immenses mais pour
atteindre l'autonomie stratégique pour
garantir notre souveraineté et notre
indépendance pour atteindre la
neutralité carbone oui nous avons besoin
de l'Europe en ce 9 mai comme tous les
jours face aux extrêmes et aux
populistes nous continuerons à la
défendre je vous remercie merci beaucoup
madame la Première ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Christophe
Becks pour le groupe la France insoumise
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre chers collègues
depuis des mois le peuple se mobilise
contre votre réforme des retraites
injustes et inutiles
des millions de personnes manifestent
leur de chaque journée de mobilisation
93% des actifs de ce pays expriment leur
opposition mais votre seul réponse et le
mépris et la répression en interdisant
les dispositifs sonores portatifs sans
avoir peur du ridicule ou les cartons
rouges au Stade de France mais madame la
Première ministre la page n'est pas
tournée votre projet brise Davy il
n'aura pas fallu attendre trois semaines
après sa promulgation pour que votre
contre-réforme des retraites et des
conséquences dramatiques je pense en
particulier à ces femmes à ces hommes
qui avaient négocié leur départ à la
retraite anticipée avec leurs employeurs
attendons avec impatience ce droit au
repos ces moments aux côtés de leur
famille et au sein d'associations
c'est le cas d'Olivier de la société
dorano alors que son départ à la
retraite a été célébré ayant des projets
tout tracés il devra choisir entre
prendre un congé sans solde le privant
de revenus ou revenir travailler durant
une année
choisir entre revenir travailler ou voir
ce revenu baissé voilà le progrès que
vous réservez à nos concitoyens et
concitoyennes vous demeurez sourd
revendications d'un peuple que vous
traitez avec une arrogance rarement
atteinte chers collègues il est encore
temps d'agir et de mettre un carton
rouge à ce gouvernement qui cherche à
étouffer la contestation non la page
n'est pas tournée madame la Première
ministre le 8 juin prochain votons
votons votons la loi d'abrogation pour
goûter haut et fort la voix du peuple
que nous représente merci beaucoup mon
cher collègue
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier du soft
ministre du Travail du plein emploi et
de l'insertion merci à madame la
Présidente
vous évoquez monsieur le député quelques
cas que je n'ignore pas que le
gouvernement n'ignore pas mais il faut
rappeler quelques évidences ou quelques
réalités aucun retraité aucun retraité
partiel à la retraite ne sera jamais
rappelé première chose deuxième chose
aucun individu aucun assuré pouvant
faire valoir son droit au départ à la
retraite avant le 1er septembre 2023 ne
peut être concerné par un quelconque
rappelle que ce soit les quatre vous
évoquez la société Orano vous avez cité
ils sont 16 personnes au sein d'une
société comorano sont des personnes qui
ne sont pas à la retraite qui sont
actuellement au congés et qui avec leur
direction avait négocié le solde de
congé de contrats épargnants ou de
compte épargne temps ou de congé
anticipé mais en aucun cas des retraites
mon cabinet est en lien avec chacune des
sociétés concernées et un traitement
social et individuel que chacun des
dossiers sera fait pour que personne ne
soit rappelé mais monsieur le député
permettez-moi tout simplement de vous
dire que quand vous voulez parler au nom
du peuple quand vous voulez parler au
nom des opposants permettez-moi de vous
dire qu'avec les filles ils ont bien de
bien piètre et mauvais port de parole
vous n'avez servi à rien dans ce débat
vous n'avez pas bougé une ligne du texte
vous n'avez pas défendu les salariés
vous avez voulu bloquer le débat et en
réalité vous n'avez rien apporté votre
seule fonction monsieur le député et de
mettre le bazar ici de mettre le bazar
dans la rue peut-être que vous êtes fier
de ceux qui parmi vous appellent à
décapiter le président de la République
où lui promettent un destin la Kennedy
ça n'est pas notre conception de la
République et ce n'est pas notre
conception la démocratie
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est à monsieur le Président
Anglade pour le comprenais sens merci
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre en ce 9 mai nous célébrons la
cornée de l'Europe et le discours
fondateur de Robert Schuman depuis
maintenant 6 ans au sein de la majorité
nous portons une exigence d'action et de
refondation du projet européen à travers
un agada de souveraineté proposé aux
Français par le Président de la
République et durant ces six années nous
avons avancé résolument sur ce chemin du
plan de relance européen à la stratégie
d'acquisition des vaccins en passant par
la lutte contre le dérèglement
climatique et bien sûr notre réponse
commune face à l'avance l'invasion russe
en Ukraine l'Europe a montré ses
dernières années sa capacité à résister
à protéger et même à dépasser ses dogmes
mais nous avons besoin de continuer à
transformer l'Europe de la coopération
en Europe de la puissance nous sommes à
ce moment charnières de notre histoire
où nous devons fort de nos réussites
nous projeter dans l'avenir du modèle
européen et de son autonomie stratégique
nous sommes dans un temps où les menaces
géopolitiques
climatique les évolutions technologiques
majeures donnent à l'Europe une
responsabilité particulière nous sommes
aussi dans un temps où les ennemis de
l'Europe restent nombreux y compris dans
cette émission ou certains alors que
Vladimir Poutine en ce jour menace
encore l'Europe et nos valeurs préfèrent
dépenser toute leur énergie pour
dénigrer le drapeau européen et à
travers lui l'unité européenne cela à
l'extrême droite et à l'extrême gauche
joue un jeu dangereux car l'Europe
indépendante est souveraine et le
meilleur levier de puissance et de
protection madame la Première ministre
le 9 mai 2022 le président de la
République concluait la conférence sur
l'avenir de l'Europe cette conférence ce
sont les états généraux de l'Europe
avant la révolution européenne de la
puissance que nous appelons de nos vœux
et qui est absolument essentiel si nous
voulons répondre aux enjeux de notre
époque et notamment celui de
l'intégration de l'Ukraine au sein de
l'Union européenne madame la Première
ministre dans ce siècle redevenu
incertain nous voulons continuer à faire
de l'Europe un continent le continent le
plus écologique le plus in novant le
plus protecteur celui qui défend les
valeurs de liberté et de démocratie
pouvez-vous nous indiquer la feuille de
route du gouvernement pour y parvenir je
vous remercie merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président la parole est à madame la
Première ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Pierre-Alexandre Anglade monsieur le
Président Pierre Alexandre de lad il y a
73 ans Robert Schuman posait les
fondements de notre construction
européenne
sa déclaration c'était d'abord une
promesse de paix le retour de la guerre
aux portes de l'Europe avec l'agression
russe en Ukraine rappelle que la peine a
rien d'une évidence quelle est précieuse
et que l'Union européenne nous l'apporte
au quotidien c'est mon premier message
notamment pour notre jeunesse mon
deuxième message c'est que l'Europe est
devenue synonyme d'action et de
solutions au service des peuples au
service des Français c'est tout le sens
de l'engagement du président de la
République depuis 2017 on disait
l'Europe fragile face aux crises c'est
grâce à l'Europe que nous avons pu
mutualiser l'achat de vaccins et
relancer massivement nos économies
on la disait naïve sur le plan
commercial elle a su imposer que les
produits importés respectent les mêmes
standards environnementaux que les
produits européens on disait à l'origine
quel était un marché aujourd'hui
l'Europe devient une puissance une
puissance qui défend ses intérêts et
veut conquérir son indépendance avec un
agenda d'autonomie stratégique pour les
matières premières critiques et pour les
médicaments avec une nouvelle politique
industrielle tournée vers la transition
écologique et le numérique une puissance
qui promet ses valeurs en luttant contre
le travail forcé contre les produits
issus de la déforestation ou pour la
régulation du numérique une puissance
sociale qui promet l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes et impose à chaque
pays de se doter d'un salaire minimum
enfin l'Europe devient une puissance
géopolitique en réagissant de manière
unanime face à la Russie en finançant la
livraison gendarmes pour aider l'Ukraine
en renforçant sa sécurité et sa défense
je n'ignore rien des défis qui restent à
relever qu'il s'agisse de l'énergie des
migrations ou des futurs élargissements
nous sommes lucides sur le chemin qui
reste à parcourir mais face au cynique
qui caricature l'Europe et lui prête
tous les mots face aux prétendu patriote
qui affirment qu'il faudrait choisir
entre l'amour de la France et
l'attachement à l'Europe j'assume de
dire que l'Europe est l'un des projets
les plus importants à battus j'assume de
dire que souveraineté nationale et
souveraineté européenne se renforce
mutuellement sans nations fortes
l'Europe et fragile mais sans Europe
puissante nous nations seront plus
faibles je suis fier d'être à la tête
d'une majorité qui est la seule famille
politique résolument pro-européenne
et je le revendique entre les extrêmes
et nous il y aura toujours l'Europe
mesdames et messieurs les députés en ce
9 mai je souhaite à tous nos
compatriotes une belle fête de l'Europe
en leur rappelant à un an des élections
européennes que l'Europe est un combat
et que la majorité présidentielle est
décidée à le mener je vous remercie
je vous remercie
merci beaucoup madame la Première
ministre la parole est à Madame
Francesca pascuini pour le groupe
écologiste merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse au ministre de
l'Intérieur samedi des croix celtiques
des nationalistes se révolutionnaires
des cagoules et des masques noirs en
défilé à Paris sous la bannière du
comité du neuf mais en hommage à
militant du groupe btenniste l'oeuvre
française décédée en 94 des images
terrifiantes alors qu'un assistant
parlementaire a été passé à tabac par
cette même extrême droite une semaine
plus tôt je souhaiterais faire remarquer
la présence dans ce cortège dans séance
trésorier du micro-partie de Madame Le
Pen que des membres du groupe Union
défense et des ex doivent Paris et oui
on ne masque pas ses origines si
facilement cette manifestation n'a pas
été interdite car selon le préfet de
police elle ne constitue pas un risque
de troubles à l'ordre public elle a donc
été autorisé et encadrée par la police
comme à chaque année mais ce pas parce
que l'ennemi est silencieux et marche
pas sans déborder qu'il n'est pas
dangereux comment se célébrer le 8 mai
45 sans dénoncer la violence intrinsèque
de ces groupes d'extrême droite il est
inconcevable que l'État ne les considère
pas par le recensement comme un trouble
à l'ordre public il y avait pourtant
fondement à interdire ce cortège je vais
vous dire sur quelle base en reprenant
les mots du président italien Pertini le
fascisme ce n'est pas une opinion c'est
un crime bien que ces manifestants
étaient tentés de dissimuler leur
identité nous ne sommes pas dupe nous
serons toujours les reconnaître même
sous les tissus les plus sombres les
ennemis de la République vous préférez
vous en prendre à ceux qui battent le
pavé à visage découvert pour défendre
leurs droits à la retraite et à la
démocratie plutôt qu'à donner aux nazis
ma question est la suivante monsieur le
ministre entendez-vous le vol noir des
corbeaux sur nos plaines entendez-vous
les cris sourds du pays comme enchaîne
je vous remercie
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur
la parole est à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
merci madame la Présidente de j'ai
député madame la députée vous avez
parfaitement raison ce qui s'est passé
dans les rues de Paris pour cette
[Musique]
manifestation est évidemment
inacceptable et la première ministre a
eu raison de dire que c'est vu de
manifestants étaient profondément
choquant pour la République je voudrais
je voudrais vous dire que cette
manifestation n'a pas été déposée
contrairement à ce que j'ai pu entendre
par un collectif ou par une association
mais par un individu isolé et que cette
personne
comme individu isolée bien évidemment le
préfet de police c'est ce que nous
pensons puisque déjà en moi janvier
dernier sur le même motif nous avons
souhaité interdire cette manifestation
que le tribunal administratif de Paris
et je le regrette nous a semé
malheureusement de pouvoir laisser
s'organiser cette manifestation de
présentait pas a priori les difficultés
qui nous permettaient sur le code que
vote les parlementaires le tribunal a
jugé trois mois avant monsieur le député
je veux dire par ailleurs que si il y a
eu s'il y a eu des s'il y a eu des
violences qui ont été commises vous avez
parlé d'un attaché parlementaire aucune
plainte à ma connaissance et celle du
préfet de police a été déposé je vous
encourage à faire déposer ses plaintes
le plus rapidement possible pour que la
police puisse faire des enquêtes et je
rappelle que c'est bien notre
gouvernement qui pour les oies qui
pourra le varium qui pour Bordeaux
nationaliste qui pour génération
identitaire avant dissous des groupes
d'extrême droite qui était là depuis
parfois plus de 30 ans sur le territoire
national
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup la parole est à Madame
Elsa faucillon pour le groupe Gauche
démocrate et républicaine
merci madame la Présidente votre
opération tournait la page est un fiasco
vos tentatives de diversion ne peuvent
effacer votre passage en force
s'agissant d'une réforme qui est abîme
si durement si concrètement si
brutalement la vie des gens et les
premières victimes sont bien réelles ce
sont ces femmes et ces hommes qui après
toute une vie professionnelle avait
planifié leur des parents en retraite
alors oui ils étaient en congé de
carrière car leur projet c'était bien de
partir en retraite et ils sont
aujourd'hui contraints de revenir au
travail
pour faire la jonction avec leur
nouvelle date de départ à leur retraite
il aurait proposé de prendre un congé
sans solde ou de reprendre leur poste
avec un salaire lissé donc diminué et
vous savez très bien monsieur le
ministre qu'il n'y aura pas que les 16
dorano et ce sont aussi des milliers de
femmes et d'hommes suspendus à la
publication des décrets d'application
pour déterminer s'ils devront ou non
retirer leur demande de départ à la
retraite ou consentir à une décote de
leur pension ce sont encore ces
travailleurs et travailleuses venus du
Maghreb ou d'Afrique sur saharienne qui
occupe les métiers les plus pénibles qui
ont des retraites de misère à cause de
carrière hachées faites d'Intérim et de
périodes mâles ou non déclarées par leur
employeur et ils découvrent
qu'aujourd'hui leur faudra rester 9 mois
en France et non plus 6 pour des
bénéficier de la SPA du jour au
lendemain ce sont des projets de vie que
vous brisez des mois des années de vie
que vous volez on hésite alors à savoir
quoi juger sur votre gouvernement votre
manque d'anticipation ou votre
malhonnêteté et vu le précédent sur les
carrières longues et sur les 1200 euros
permettez-nous d'y voir un mensonge de
plus un mensonge pour cacher votre
déconnexion abyssale avec la vie des
Français une marque de mépris
supplémentaires et à n'en pas douter
votre réforme nous réserve encore
beaucoup trop beaucoup trop de mauvaises
surprises alors non décidément nous ne
tournerons pas la page elle ne se tourne
pas comme ça c'est pourquoi les députés
du groupe GDR comme tous ceux de la
nupesse seront bien sûr en rendez-vous
du 6 juin dans la rue mais le 8 juin
aussi ici même pour obtenir
merci beaucoup la
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier du soft
ministre du Travail de l'insertion et du
plein emploi merci madame la présidente
madame la députée vous avez évoqué la
réponse que j'ai commencé à faire à
Monsieur beige tout à l'heure je vais
continuer simplement pour appeler et
vous l'avez dit vous-même aucun retraité
n'est rappelé aucun et aucune personne
aucun assuré qui peut faire valoir son
départ à la retraite dans les conditions
prévues par la loi avant le 1er
septembre 2023 ne peut être concerné par
un quelconque rappelle il y a un certain
nombre de salariés vous l'avez dit je
l'ai dit qui à l'occasion d'un compte
épargne en haut d'un congé de fin de
carrière aujourd'hui un âge de départ
qui va être décalé trois mois et cela
peut poser quelques problèmes de
tuilages qui vont me permettez cette
expression je lui ai dit tout à l'heure
nous sommes en contact avec chacune des
sociétés concernées pour les 16
personnes chez Orano mais il y en a
d'autres dans d'autres sociétés
industrielles et nous travaillons en
lien avec les équipes de la première
ministre pour convaincre les entreprises
ainsi concernées qu'elles peuvent
t'accompagner socialement les personnes
qui sont concernées c'est le travail que
nous faisons conférence sorte que
personne n'est un revenir nous y
travaillons et nous le en sachant que le
nombre de cas global ne sera pas un
nombre de cas très élevé pour deux
raisons la première c'est que vous le
savez pour bénéficier d'un congé de fin
de carrière ou d'un compte épargne tant
crédité de un an ou plus d'un an et
c'est quand même une situation
relativement rare et qui plutôt le cas
de très grande entreprise et donc nous
assurons ce suivi là avec la plus grande
attention la deuxième partie de votre
question madame la députée concernait
les décrets d'application les principaux
décrets notamment sur ce qu'on appelle
parfois les mesures paramétriques
décalage de l'âge de départ un raison
d'un trimestre par an ou accélération de
la réforme de 2013 ont été transmis aux
caisses pour avis ils seront publiés
très rapidement mais il y a une
certitude c'est qu'ils sont parfaitement
conformes à la loi dans toutes celles et
ceux qui devraient vous interroger
peuvent s'appuyer sur la loi et les
exposer des motifs comme l'ensemble des
documents puisque les décrets sont
parfaitement conformes ils concernent
l'âge concernent la durée de cotisation
il concerne aussi au 1er septembre la
revalorisation des pensions minimum les
nouvelles règles de prise en compte des
carrières longues l'ouverture à la
fonction publique de la retraite
progressive ou encore la libéralisation
de celle-ci pour le secteur privé en 1er
septembre ça n'est pas seulement une
question d'âge c'est l'ensemble des
mesures de la réforme qui entreront en
vigueur je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Gouffier valent pour le groupe
Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente préalablement
à ma question qui s'adressera à Madame
la Ministre délégué chargée de
l'organisation territoriale et des
professions de santé en cette Journée de
l'Europe je tiens à affirmer au nom du
groupe Renaissance tout notre soutien
aux femmes et aux hommes qui se battent
en Europe et ailleurs dans le monde pour
la défense du droit à l'avortement
madame la ministre depuis plusieurs
semaines le gouvernement est interpellé
sur les tensions d'approvisionnement de
mise au poste cette molécule
indispensable pour réaliser les IVG
médicamenteuses qui est la solution
privilégiée par les femmes qui
souhaitent avorter cette situation
complique l'accès dans les officines de
ville aux médicaments qui contiennent
cette molécule notamment le gimizo et le
miso one c'est à dire à la pilule
abortive si toutefois nous ne pouvons
pas parler de pénurie puisque des stocks
d'au moins un mois existe dans
l'ensemble des centres des
établissements de santé c'est tension
ponctuelle interroge et un quête de
manière légitime aussi pouvez-vous nous
dire les raisons de ces difficultés les
mesures qui sont prises par le
gouvernement pour la résorber en outre
madame la ministre alors même que le
droit à l'avortement est aujourd'hui
attaqué de manière organisée régulière
par les mouvements conservateurs et
d'extrême droite partout à travers le
monde y compris en Europe et en France
nous nous devons d'entendre les
inquiétudes plus globales que révèlent
les interpellations de ces dernières
semaines et au moment même où nous
travaillons à la constitutionnalisation
du droit à l'avortement à sa
reconnaissance dans la Charte des droits
fondamentaux de l'Union européenne cet
épisode vient nous rappeler l'enjeu
majeur de l'égal accès de toutes les
femmes à l'avortement c'est en jeu nous
le sous le Vion déjà avec la délégation
au droit des femmes en mars et en
novembre 2022 et c'est en jeu vous le
savez pour notre groupe Renaissance il
est majeur en 2023 en France il n'est
pas acceptable que des femmes qui
souhaitent avorter rencontre des
difficultés voire pire renonce aussi
pouvez-vous nous dire quels sont les
mesures mises en place pour le
gouvernement pour garantir les galaxies
de toutes les femmes à l'IVG et au fond
le respect de leurs droits à disposer de
leur corps je vous remercie je vous
remercie mon cher collègue la parole est
à Madame Firmin le Bodo ministre délégué
chargé de l'organisation territoriale et
des professions de santé merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le députés Gouffier
Valentin je vous prie tout d'abord
d'excuser l'absence du ministrat la
santé de la prévention François Brune
retenue au Sénat cet après-midi en cette
Journée de l'Europe permets-moi
permettez-moi tout d'abord d'avoir une
pensée pour Simone Veil première femme
présidente du Parlement européen et qui
a fait du combat pour l'émancipation des
femmes et l'accès à l'IVG le cœur de son
engagement politique
les difficultés que vous évoquez
concernent des tensions sur le
fabrication de deux médicaments à base
de misoprostol fournies par un seul
laboratoire le laboratoire suédois
nordique Pharma avec un
dysfonctionnement dans la chaîne de
production pour le médicament jimiso et
un problème dans l'analyse du contrôle
qualité pour le médicament mise au one
ayant décalé la production pendant 3
mois des connaissances de l'ex de
l'existence d'éventuels tensions le
ministre s'est assuré que la NSM avait
pris toutes les mesures nécessaires pour
garantir son accès aux professionnels de
santé et au centre
IVG concernant les spécialités à base de
misoprostol des livraisons de la
spécialité jimiso 46500 boîtes couvrant
plus de trois mois de consommation
habituelles ont débuté depuis le 7 avril
dernier dans les circuits villes et
hôpital ces livraisons ont permis
d'honorer les reliquats de commandes à
hauteur de 6000 watts les 40 500 boîtes
restantes assurent une couverture large
des besoins pour les prochaines semaines
dans l'attente de la prochaine livraison
prévue début juin il s'agit notamment de
mesure de contingentement pour garantir
une distribution plus régulière et
l'importation de produit destinés à
d'autres marchés concernant la
spécialité mise au one les
approvisionnements de la présentation
hospitalière de 16 comprimés couvrent
les besoins mensuels mais des tensions
subsistent sur la présentation en boîte
de une comprimé de un comprimé depuis
fin avril des livraisons à hauteur de
45000 boîtes sont en cours permettant de
normaliser durablement la situation afin
de consolider la situation des
approvisionnements une importation de la
spécialité italienne est en cours de
destination des circuits villes hôpital
le ministère de la santé la prévention
en lien étroit avec la NSM suivi
évidemment avec attention la situation
vous pouvez compter sur mon engagement
et celui de l'ensemble du gouvernement
pour garantir la planifivité de l'accès
à l'IVG pour toutes les femmes merci
beaucoup madame la ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Alexis Corbière
pour le groupe la France insoumise merci
monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
nationale jeudi 4 mai le président de la
République a annoncé un profond
bouleversement de l'enseignement
professionnel avec en phase il a déclaré
je le cite ce n'est pas seulement une
réforme c'est une cause nationale certes
l'enseignement professionnel qui
accueille un tiers des lycéens le
mériterait mais votre projet n'est pas
une cause mais une casse nationale
si on vous laisse faire vous allez
briser la spécificité de notre
enseignement professionnel qui malgré
des difficultés méritent précisément
beaucoup plus que ça vos annonces
sidaires par les dégâts qu'elles vont et
qu'elles annonces qu'elles vont causer
qu'elles annonces elles manifestent
surtout une méconnaissance totale de la
réalité dans beaucoup de médias monsieur
le ministre vous avez annoncé que le la
philosophie de votre réforme s'est
rapproché le lycée professionnel du
monde de l'entreprise mais c'est déjà le
cas tous les diplômes de l'enseignement
professionnel tous sans exception sont
définies dans des commissions en
présence de branches patronales c'est
aussi le cas pour la carte des
formations
des formations mais pourquoi faire
croire le contraire dans quel but alors
que tous les élèves de terminale ont
déjà huit semaines de stage vous
proposez d'en rajouter 50% sans la
moindre justification pédagogique votre
modèle semble être celui de
l'apprentissage contre la formation
publique mais vous savez qu'aujourd'hui
trois élèves 4 sous statut scolaire vont
jusqu'au bac quand c'est seulement 2 sur
5 qui arrive dans l'apprentissage vous
annoncez des fumeux lycées des bureaux
d'entreprise dans les lycées
professionnels qui en mérité ne
serviront qu'à répondre aux besoins
immédiats et à courtes vue du patronat
vous proposez une rémunération pour les
enseignants mais à monsieur le ministre
vous n'êtes que dans le slogan éculé de
Sarkozy je vous ignorer d'ailleurs en
accord avec lui je vous ai connu
autrement travaillez plus pour gagner
plus vous annoncez une gratification
pour les élèves nous disons OUI à l'aide
pour les enfants mais pas avec de l'aide
publique bref doute vous laisseront pas
faire au lycée professionnel ce que vous
avez fait pour les retraites retirez
votre réforme
la parole est à madame Carole Grandjean
ministre délégué chargé de
l'enseignement et de la formation
professionnelle merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député Corbières
l'enseignement professionnel doit
d'abord être crédible dans les
entreprises pour déboucher sur des
emplois
ce n'est pas une citation de la majorité
c'est une citation de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
Jean-Luc Mélenchon alors ministre de
l'Enseignement professionnel en 2000 en
fait
ce qu'il n'a pas fait nous allons le
faire notre ambition elle est claire
faire de la voie professionnelle une
voix qui insère une voix de choix une
voix d'excellence pour cela nous
l'assumons nous allons rapprocher
l'école de l'entreprise la voie
professionnelle doit être
professionnalisante elle doit
effectivement ouvrir des olives s'il
vous plaît
nous allons donc réparer finalement
cette méconnaissance des entreprises
accentuer le manque de réseau
professionnel des jeunes qui est un
obstacle majeur dans l'accès au premier
emploi nous allons y mettre les moyens
ce qu'il faudra faire pour accompagner
les élèves c'est notamment la
gratification des périodes de formation
en milieu professionnel mais également
l'augmentation du nombre de semaine de
stage avec un montant de gratification
qui ira de 600 à 1200 euros pour
certains élèves en Terminale cette
mesure mesdames et messieurs les députés
de la France insoumise Monsieur
Mélenchon l'a proposé lorsqu'il était
ministre s'il avait mis autant de fougue
dans les lycées professionnels que dans
les veines polémiques nous aurions
peut-être avancé aujourd'hui Emmanuel
Macron l'avait annoncé et il le fait
mais non nous ne recommençons pas à la
scolarisation des jeunes pour autant au
contraire nous allons corriger ces
fragilités des élèves au lycée
professionnel les matières fondamentales
seront donc renforcées de cette rentrée
2023 puis encore à la rentrée 2024 grâce
notamment à la proposition de
sous-groupe permettant de mieux les
accompagner en mathématiques et français
alors vous le voyez mesdames et
messieurs les députés nous nous
satisfaisons pas du statu quo qui
conduit nos jeunes à l'échec nous
portons une réforme ambitieuse le
gouvernement investit plus d'un milliard
d'euros par an supplémentaires notre
objectif est clair 0 décrochage 100%
d'insertion
la parole est à Madame Marietta
carrément libre pour le groupe
socialiste
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur le Ministre de l'économie selon
le FCE l'inflation restera élevée
jusqu'à la fin de l'année 2023 dans
notre pays entre 5 et demi et 6 et demi
pour cent cette forte hausse générale
des prix à la consommation affectera
aussi bien le pouvoir d'achat des
ménages que la croissance du PIB
français est le niveau de chômage du
pays le gouvernement prédisait il y a
deux mois une baisse d'ici l'été nous
n'y serons pas en mars dernier institut
national de la statistique des études
économiques a fait état d'une
augmentation de près de 15% des prix
alimentaires sur 12 mois évidemment des
mesures ont été prises mais on est loin
du compte l'accès au bien du première
nécessité aux dépenses contraintes
devient très difficile pour les plus
modestes les petits salaires jugent au
dessus du SMIC et sans
indexation n'ont aucune perspective
d'évolution les retraites de base ont
augmenté de 0,8% au 1er janvier 2023
mais une inflation de plus de 5% l'année
passée dans de nombreux territoires
ruraux et périurbain la facture
énergétique et encore plus forte
qu'ailleurs 20 à 40% avec des logements
moins isolés et plus énergivores si la
prime rénove a suscité de l'intérêt et
ses transformer en galère avec des
travaux à payer sans versement rapide et
déprime alors que la Commission
européenne plaidait pour taxer les super
profits dans le secteur de l'énergie
vous avez refusé alors que de nombreux
économistes aujourd'hui plaides pour
faire et contribuer les hyper riches qui
n'ont un taux d'imposition effective que
de 2%, vous vous refusez pour des
raisons purement d'idées à restaurer la
justice fiscale alors des propositions
existent la baisse des taxes de mission
d'énergie les négociations salariales
pour accélérer l'augmentation des
salaires notamment ceux des plus
modestes des nouvelles mesures en
matière d'accès à la rénovation
énergétique pour l'abaissement des
seuils et un zéro à charge pour le plus
modeste alors ma question est donc
simple qu'allez-vous faire monsieur le
ministre qu'avez-vous faire ce
gouvernement merci beaucoup
ma chère collègues la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier du soft
ministre du Travail de l'insertion et du
plein emploi
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la député
carrément Lee permettez-moi de vous
répondre à la fois comme une liste du
travail mais aussi comme ancien ministre
des comptes publics pour dire madame la
députée que
si
votre groupe madame la député avait voté
toutes les mesures soutien pour pouvoir
d'achat votre critique serait un peu
plus fondé nous sommes je crois le
gouvernement qui a mis en place le plus
de mesures des mesures de lutte contre
l'inflation des mesures d'accompagnement
des ménages notamment pour la prise la
prise en charge des factures
énergétiques des mesures aussi pour
faire en sorte que face à cette
inflation le partage de la valeur soit
véritablement au rendez-vous je prendrai
deux exemples d'abord par le fait que
nous avons mis en œuvre et c'est normal
c'est la loi les revalorisations du SMIC
au risque de l'inflation avec une
revalorisation du SMIC de 6,2% sur un an
nous veillons comme le faisait ma
prédécesseur au ministère du Travail la
première ministre aujourd'hui à ce que
le comité de suivi des négociations
salariales puis cette pleinement actif
de manière à ce que chaque fois qu'une
branche voit un des niveaux
conventionnels passer en dessous du SMIC
le dialogue social puisse être lancé et
nous aurons l'occasion dans les toutes
prochaines semaines la madame la députée
de soumettre à l'Assemblée un projet de
loi permettant de transposer dans la loi
la Cour nationale interprofessionnel en
matière de partage de de la valeur
permettant puisqu'il a été signé par
quatre des cinq organisations syndicales
et trois organisations patronales
d'avancer d'avancer en matière
d'intéressement et de participation dans
les entreprises de 11 à 50 salariés
d'avancer aussi dans le cas des
entreprises qui réalisent des résultats
exceptionnels pour qu'elle puisse verser
en intéressement qui soit tout aussi
exceptionnel à chaque fois nous serons
au rendez-vous j'espère que vous le
serez avec nous cette fois-ci et pas
comme les fois précédentes je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Madame Alexandra Masson
pour le rassemblement national
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur
monsieur Darmanin le 5 mai dernier un
migrant guinéen lancé en direct sur BFM
TV on va vous envahir il était au poste
frontière de menton dans ma
circonscription quelques minutes après
que j'ai constaté moi-même que ce poste
du pont Saint-Louis ne faisait l'objet
d'aucun contrôle de police et ce malgré
vos annonces de renfort deux jours plus
tôt avec Jordan Bardella et mes
collègues Bryan Masson et Lionel Tivoli
nous avions pu constater pour la énième
fois que les effectifs de la police aux
frontières étaient largement
insuffisants face à la vague migratoire
qui a quadruplé en moins d'un an en
réponse à cette déferlante nous vous
n'avez trouvé rien de mieux que de
traiter la chef du gouvernement italien
d'incapable
comme vous n'êtes pas un paradoxe près
en novembre c'est exactement l'inverse
Georgia Meloni était inhumaine et
irresponsable en refusant d'accueillir
les ONG qui récupèrent les migrants dans
les olibiènes vos propos monsieur le
ministre et vos actions sont
désastreuses vos déclarations
irresponsables au moment où nos deux
pays doivent plus que jamais être
partenaires vous avez affaibli eterni
l'image de la France en Italie mais
aussi auprès des milliers d'Italiens qui
vivent et qui travaillent chaque jour
dans notre pays monsieur le ministre
allez vous présenter vos excuses à
l'Italie et allez vous enfin prendre vos
responsabilités et installer de manière
pérenne des effectifs à cette frontière
qui se protégera les Français merci
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Gérald Darmanin ministre de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs débutez madame la député maçon
vous l'avez dit vous-même depuis le 1er
janvier venant d'Italie c'est 4200
personnes qui se sont présentés
présentés par nous en 2023 c'est-à-dire
4 fois plus en une année et en parallèle
vous auriez pu remercier les forces de
l'ordre madame la députée puisque c'est
80% d'interpellation et de refoulement à
la frontière franco-italienne de plus
par nos forces de l'ordre vous avez pas
eu un mot pour eux moi je veux ici les
remercier
non mais vous avez le droit de pas
soutenir les forces de l'ordre vous
énervez pas comme ça
[Applaudissements]
je veux
allez-y monsieur le ministre je veux ici
vous dire qu'en effet il faudrait que
tous les pays européens se mettent
d'accord pour qu'il y ait des contrôles
externes de frontières de l'Europe ce
qu'on appelle l'enregistrement pour
pouvoir effectivement refouler les
personnes aux frontières de l'Europe
c'est vrai c'est vrai qu'il faudrait
aussi une procédure d'asile unique pour
éviter les difficultés que vous évoquez
c'est vrai c'est vrai qu'il faudrait
également revoir totalement le règlement
Dublin parce que nos amis italien ne
reprennent quasiment plus de personnes
du binées c'est tellement vrai madame la
députée que au Parlement européen vous
faites l'inverse d'ici et l'inverse de
votre circonscription monsieur Bardella
votre chef du parti le 20 avril dernier
à voter contre le mandat de négociation
pour que ces problèmes soient résolus
madame vous vivez que des problèmes nous
essayons de les résoudre
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
madame la députée
monsieur Darmanin les forces de l'offre
comme je vous le dis régulièrement
depuis le 2 août je pense que je les
soutiens beaucoup plus que vous au poste
frontières parce que moi j'y suis
régulièrement et je suis là à les
écouter dans des difficultés terribles
parce que ce que vous oubliez de dire
c'est qu'on ne réglant pas le problème
obligatoire tous les jours vous les
mettez en danger et régulièrement il y a
des accidents et les forces de l'ordre
souffrent beaucoup plus que ce que vous
ne le pensez sur place alors arrêtez
d'être incompétent venez sur place et
régler le problème je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre
je constate maintenant député qu'il a
fallu que je vous fasse sa remarque pour
vous souteniez les policiers c'est un
progrès
et vous devez pas être très souvent dans
votre circonscription parce que vous
auriez constaté alors que 286 est arrivé
dans votre circonscription je crois que
280 CRS ça se voit encore faut-il que
vous ayez les rencontrer oh merci
monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Madame Agnès car elle
pour le groupe horizon merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse au
ministre de l'économie des finances et
de la souveraineté économique le pouvoir
d'achat reste la préoccupation majeure
des Français l'inflation touche de plein
fouet la majorité de nos concitoyens
malgré la hausse du SMIC du de ce
premier mai que nous saluons les bas
salaires se voient rattraper par ceux
qui touchent le SMIC et les difficultés
pour finir les fins de moi sont le lot
commun de beaucoup de nos administrés le
sentiment des Français que
l'augmentation des prix notamment dans
l'alimentation et sans fin l'inflam
l'inflation effectivement continuer de
grimper avec une hausse dans ce domaine
de 15,8% en mars sur un an pourtant le
coût de l'énergie abaissé tout comme
celui du transport et du blé a perdu 15%
depuis deux mois ainsi que 35% pour
l'engrais ce constat s'applique aussi
pour la plupart des matières premières
mais ne se traduit pas par exemple à la
pompe pour nos concitoyens malgré la
baisse
significative du prix du baril certes en
France les prix ne sont pas recalculés
automatiquement puisqu'il y a des rues
de négociation qu'une fois par an et
qu'elles ont déjà eu lieu pour cette
année mais concrètement les industriels
et les distributeurs semblent profiter
de cette situation aussi monsieur le
ministre vous avez demandé aux
industriels industriels de
l'aggloiementaire et à la grande
distribution de nouvelles négociations
commerciales pour faire baisser les prix
dans les magasins le gouvernement
souhaite qu'après l'État et les
distributeurs qui ont fait des efforts
avec le trimestre anti-inflation en
prenant sur leur marge ce soit autour
des industriels de l'agroalimentaire de
prendre leur part pour répercuter la
baisse des cours de certaines matières
premières comme par exemple le blé
vous espérez ainsi une base visible des
prix à la rentrée de septembre grâce à
cette réouverture des négociations mais
les Français attendent la rentrée et la
rentrée leur semble loin beaucoup trop
loin pouvez-vous nous faire un point sur
ces avancées et rassurer nos concitoyens
à l'approche de l'été merci Merci
beaucoup ma chère collègue la parole est
à Monsieur Bruno Le Maire ministre de
l'Économie des Finances de la
souveraineté industrielle et numérique
madame la Présidente et député madame la
députée Agnès Carrel il y a un an
les grands industriels étaient venus
nous voir avec Olivia Grégoire avec le
ministre de l'Industrie Roland Lescure
on nous disant les prix du fret
maritimes sont en train de flamber sont
passés à 12000 13000 15000 euros le
conteneur les prix du blé sont en train
de flamber les prix du pétrole sont en
train de flamber il faut absolument que
nous puissions répercuter tout de suite
cette augmentation des prix de gros sur
les prix de détails sinon chez nos
industries qui vont être menacés nous
leur avons répondu et nous leur avons
permis d'indexer l'augmentation des prix
de gros sur les prix de détails et nous
l'avons fait tout de suite pour protéger
nos industriels et protéger nos emplois
aujourd'hui les prix de gros sont en
train de baisser les prix du fret sont
en train de baisser les prix du blé sont
en train de baisser et les prix du brut
sont également très faibles les
industriels doivent s'en délai
répercuter cette baisse des prix de gros
sur les prix de détails pour protéger
nos compatriotes contre l'augmentation
des prix ingumentaires qui est un
supportable pour eux je verrai cette
semaine les distributeurs pour examiner
avec eux comment est-ce qu'ils peuvent
prolonger le trimestre anti-inflation
au-delà du 15 juin la semaine prochaine
je réunirai tous les grands industriels
notamment ceux de l'agroalimentaire mais
pas uniquement l'agroalimentaire pour
leur demander de répercuter sans délai
dans les négociations commerciales la
baisse des prix de gros sur les prix de
détails pour protéger nos compatriotes
contre cette spirale infasionniste qui
est insupportable pour eux soit ils
acceptent de rentrer dans le jeu de
cette négociation et de répercuter à la
baisse les prix de gros sur les prix de
détails soit nous le voyons aucun
mouvement et dans ce cas là nous nous
réservons avec Roland Lescure avec
Olivia le Grégoire le droit d'utiliser
tous les moyens à notre disposition pour
que ces prix baissent et que nos
compatriotes payent leurs produits
alimentaires moins cher merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre ma chère collègues
on compte sur vous monsieur le ministre
il faut redonner du pouvoir d'achat et
on les Français nous attendent et ces
signaux les remettrai en confiance merci
à vous ma chère collègues
la parole est à Madame Estelle
Youssoupha pour le groupe lot merci
madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'Intérieur et
des Outre-mer Gérald Darmanin monsieur
le ministre alors que la police et la
gendarmerie multiplie les arrestations
d'envergure sur le terrain la
mobilisation de Mayotte pour soutenir
l'opération en bouchon ne faiblit pas
des milliers de nos compatriotes ont
encore défilé ce week-end à Aqua dans le
nord de l'huile mais aussi à Lyon
Marseille et Saint-Denis de la Réunion
cette extraordinaire mobilisation
citoyenne mahoraise traduit notre
aspiration à vivre en sécurité notre
reconnaissance pour les efforts déployés
pour nous permettre de retrouver une vie
normale cette mobilisation traduit aussi
notre gratitude pour l'écoute et pour la
solidarité pour Mayotte exprimer ici
au-delà des clivages partisans mais
aussi dans les médias et lors des
manifestations être enfin entendu que
compatriotes nous comprennent et
capitales cela nous redonne à nous
espoir pour l'avenir de Mayotte et pour
cela nous vous disons merci ici à tous
cette mobilisation citoyenne porte aussi
la dignité le courage d'un peuple face
aux mensonge du président comorien qui
encourage implicitement la terreur et
qui nie notre souveraineté nationale à
Mayotte azalik qui se permet ici à Paris
de faire la leçon à la France et de
bloquer l'un des volets de l'opération
en bouchon en refusant de reprendre ses
ressortissants en situation irrégulière
le chef de l'État comorien qui s'est
entretenu avec le président de la
République Emmanuel Macron hier à
l'Élysée ma question est la suivante
monsieur le ministre c'est négociations
diplomatiques ont-elles abouti les
Comores vont-elles enfin permettre les
reconduites à la frontière je vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole est
à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin ministre de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Estelle Youssoupha d'abord merci de
votre soutien à l'action du gouvernement
mais surtout des femmes et des hommes de
l'État et singulièrement bien sûr des
forces de l'ordre sur l'autorité du
préfet que je voudrais ici une nouvelle
fois saluer puisque depuis que cette
opération a été déclenchée c'est 134
interpellations qui ont eu lieu
notamment vous le savez un tiers des
bancs de criminels que nous avons dans
le viseur de la justice bien sûr et de
la police et de la gendarmerie ont été
interpellés sur le territoire de Mayotte
rendant ainsi évidemment très concret le
travail de paix public annoncé par
l'action voulue par le président de la
République destruction d'habitat illégal
interpellation des photos de troubles et
des délinquants et évidemment reconduite
à la frontière pour plusieurs pays le
Sri Lanka Madagascar l'Afrique des
grands lacs et bien évidemment les
Comores
depuis une dizaine de jours vous l'avez
dit les lésions maritimes mais pas
aériennes avec les Comores sont arrêtés
et nous avons avec chemise à faire
étrangères ce midi rencontrer nos
homologues et un communiqué commun et
sorti à 15h je vais vous en donner
lecture puisque les deux délégations
auraient affirmé leur volonté de lutter
contre le trafic et contre les placeurs
y compris par la reprise des liaisons
maritimes c'est-à-dire que les lésions
maritimes entre les Comores et Mayotte
vont donc reprendre c'est grâce à
l'action du Président de la République
hier a notamment reçu le président azali
le travail que nous menons à Mayotte
pour la paix publique va pouvoir
continuer et je vous l'ai dit madame la
députée nous laisserons autant d'autant
qu'il est nécessaire les policiers les
gendarmes qui tous les jours font ce
qu'aucun autre gouvernement en a fait
pour Mayotte les maorilles qui en ont
bien besoin je veux leur dire à travers
vous à travers le député Mansour
camardine que deux Mayotte nous
entendons leur soutien et nous les
remercions évidemment pour cela
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
madame Youssoupha
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Philippe
Niort pour le groupe la France insoumise
madame la Première ministre à la veille
de la commémoration de l'abolition de
l'esclavage une nouvelle forme de
servitude sabbat de plein fouet sur les
populations dites ultramarines dont la
mobilité est forcément captive pour le
seul mois de mars le coût du billet
d'avion a augmenté de plus de 50% en
Martinique et en Guadeloupe et entre le
premier et le 25 août il faudra
débourser
2231 euros pour un Paris Fort de France
contre 1037 euros pour un pari Miami la
flambée du coup du kérosène la guerre en
Ukraine n'explique pas objectivement une
telle différence de prix pour des durées
de vol équivalentes en réalité les
tarifs plus qu'abusifs imposé par des
compagnies aériennes oligopolistiques
vis-à-vis de peuple qui plie déjà sous
la vie chère constitue un véritable
scandale
depuis
1976 l'État a doté la Corse d'une
délégation de service public au titre de
la continuité territoriale il y dépense
aujourd'hui 220 millions d'euros ce qui
nous réjouit mais seulement 45 millions
d'euros pour l'ensemble des territoires
did outre-mer ce qui nous révolte madame
la Première ministre au nom du principe
d'égalité quand adopter adopterez-vous
enfin dans les territoires dix
d'outre-mer une vraie politique de
continuité territoriale dotée de vrais
moyens budgétaire à l'instar de la Corse
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs député pardon je vous prie
d'excuser Jean-François caraco qui est
actuellement à Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon
mais j'ai échangé avec lui ce matin il
veut vous dire il veut vous dire bien
évidemment que il a tout à fait
conscience et nous avons tout à fait
confiance au gouvernement sur
l'augmentation des prix vous avez raison
de l'espace aérien notamment pour nos
compatriotes des Antilles et si nous
avons monté à 50% comme vous l'avez dit
se descendu de passer et Jean-François
karaco a rendez-vous avec Bruno Le Maire
dans les tous prochains jours pour
évoquer ce sujet notamment d'inflation
des billets d'avion sur la continuité
territoriale Jean-François caraco vous
recevra avec Clément bonne à la fin de
cette semaine si vous le souhaitez au
début de semaine prochaine l'ensemble
des parlementaires d'outre-mer et
singulièrement évidemment des
parlementaires antillais je me permets
de dire monsieur le député mais vous le
savez que les collectivité local
également que vous connaissez bien ont
aussi une possibilité qu'ils n'ont pas
utilisé jusqu'à présent c'est de
contribuer avec l'État qui va faire cet
effort supplémentaire pour que pour nos
concitoyens
ultramarins on est pris soit moins cher
en lien avec les compagnies aériennes et
on vient avec le secteur économique
poussé par Bercy c'est une vraie
question que vous posez bien sûr
monsieur député l'État a apporté une
première réponse d'augmentation à 50% de
sa prise en charge il faut désormais que
nous ayons davantage encore nos
compatriotes antillais merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre monsieur Niort
monsieur le ministre je suis désolé mais
je vous parle de prix de transport
aérien et on dirait que vous voulez me
mener en bateau
dans tous nos outre-mer la colère ronde
et les gens ont de plus en plus le
sentiment de se faire racketter par les
compagnies aériennes organisées en
oligopole sous le regard complice de
l'État et de la Commission européenne
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Monsieur Mathieu Marcio
pour le rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur Bruno Le Maire
ministre de l'Économie monsieur le
ministre la colère des Français contre
la réforme des retraites ne retombe pas
cette réforme injuste et antisociale
vous êtes obstiné à la menée dans un
contexte pourtant particulièrement
difficile pour nos compatriotes l'os des
prix durement ressenti par les classes
populaires et moyennes c'est la même que
vous assommez un peu plus en les
condamnant à trimer plus longtemps au
travail ou au chômage avant de gagner
une retraite qui ne leur permettra même
pas de boucler les fins de mois vous
avez menti à tous ces Français modestes
en promettant une retraite minimum à
1200 euros et ce n'est pas les mesures
que vous annoncez qui viendront faire
oublier vos perfidis vous distribuez des
chèques qui ne sont rien une réponse
durable aux besoins des Français mais
qui vous permettent du moins vous
l'espérez d'acheter la paix sociale là
encore personne n'est dupe votre
politique gouvernementale est devenue
l'archétype d'une déconnexion profonde
avec la réalité que vivent la majorité
des français alors que des Français
peinent à faire le plein de leur
véhicule
et en assurer l'entretien vous faites la
promotion d'un plan vélo à deux
milliards d'euros
mais Monsieur le Ministre allez donc
dire aux habitants du bassin minier de
prendre leur vélo sur la roquette
minière pour aller travailler vous
n'avez décidément rien compris et vos
priorités aujourd'hui sont de créer une
cellule de comes anti-rêne ou de forcer
les mairies à poser le drapeau européen
sur leur fronton
c'est vrai qu'avec ça les gens vont
vivre mieux alors je vais vous prendre
au mot vous qui nous reprochez de citer
Marine Le Pen il est vrai que sa
popularité vous dérange je vais citer du
Emmanuel Macron pour les gens qui ne
sont rien le mépris social vous
l'arrêter quand
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Bruno Le Maire
ministre de l'Économie des Finances de
la souveraineté industrielle et
numérique
présidente
mais ce sont les solutions du
rassemblement national qui sont
totalement déconnectés de la réalité
si nous avions suivi depuis quelques
années les solutions du rassemblement
national et de Marine Le Pen pour faire
face aux problèmes des Français
qu'est-ce que cela aurait concrètement
donné nous aurions un retour à la
retraite à 60 ans qui aurait ruiné le
système de retraite par répartition
nous serions sortis de l'euro comme
l'avait proposé Marine Le Pen alors que
l'euro nous a protégé face à la crise du
covid et nous a permis d'émettre de la
dette en commun
nous aurions monsieur le député Mario
pendant la crise du covid nous aurions
tous été soignés à la chloroquine je
suis pas sûr que la santé des Français
s'en serait bien portée et si nous
avions suivi les solutions de Marine Le
Pen nous serions aujourd'hui du côté de
la Russie et pas de l'Ukraine de
l'oppresseur et pas de la liberté de la
crècheur et pas du résistant voilà la
réalité des propositions de Marine Le
Pen quant à l'inflation quelle est la
seule proposition que vous ayez porté
par le gel des prix du gaz vous n'avez
voté pas le plafonnement des prix de
l'électricité vous ne l'avez pas voté
pas l'indemnité carburant travailleur
vous n'avez pas voté pas la
revalorisation du minima sociaux vous
n'avez pas voté vous n'avez rien voté
mesdames et messieurs députés durant son
nom national de ceux qui protège
aujourd'hui les Français contre
l'inflation votre seule solution c'est
la baisse de la TVA qui va engraisser
les distributeurs au lieu de protéger
les consommateurs et nos compatriotes
oui les solutions du Front national ne
sont depuis 10 ans que des illusions et
nous cesserons de les dénoncer pour
proposer nous des solutions concrètes
efficaces et tangibles je vous remercie
monsieur ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Marquion
il y a un an en visite dans le bassin
minier manuel Macron avait entendu ce
que les gens pensaient de son projet
leur sentiment n'ont pas changé ils
n'attendent rien de vous vivement
l'alternance
oh merci la parole est à Madame
Charlotte GUTTI bolognaise pour le
groupe Renaissance
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre la semaine dernière le
président de la République détaillait
les grands axes de la réforme des lycées
professionnels lutte contre le
décrochage scolaire insertion
professionnelle et revalorisation du
travail des enseignants ces annonces
sont cruciales car elles concernent un
très grand nombre de lycéens de notre
pays en effet chaque année un collégien
sur toi s'oriente vers un lycée
professionnel ce qui représente 621 000
élèves et 64000 apprentis des annonces
importantes alors que nous entrons dans
l'Année européenne des compétences elle
devra notamment permettre une meilleure
mobilité internationale des apprentis
via le programme
Erasmus plus pendant longtemps les
lycées professionnels ont été
dévalorisés il nous appartient
aujourd'hui de leur redonner le
rayonnement qu'il mérite à ce titre nous
ne peuvent vous que nous réjouir des
mesures annoncées que ce soit en
adoptant la termin à chaque lycéen avec
une gratification des stages ou encore
un renforcement du lien entre lycée et
entreprise parce qu'une main d'oeuvre
qualifiée et synonyme d'emploi mieux
rémunérés il est primordial
d'accompagner nos jeunes vers les
secteurs d'avenir aussi madame la
ministre pouvez-vous me préciser si une
réforme de la carte des formations est
envisagée tout en tenant compte des
spécificités de chaque territoire je
vous remercie
je vous remercie ma chère collègues la
parole est à madame Carole Grandjean
ministre délégué chargé de
l'enseignement et de la formation
professionnelle merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la députés Gucci
bolognaise effectivement nous marquons
aujourd'hui pour cette journée de
l'Europe le lancement de l'Année
européenne des compétences et qui suit
l'année européenne de la jeunesse je
voudrais effectivement aussi replacer ce
contexte de la réforme du lycée
professionnel dans cette dynamique sur
laquelle la France est
avec son augmentation exceptionnelle de
l'apprentissage mais aussi sa forte
mobilisation du compte personnel de
formation avec une large popularisation
de cet outil et l'évolution de la
validation des acquis de l'expérience
que nous avons développé mais c'est
aussi tout le sens que vient prendre la
réforme des lycées professionnels que le
Président de la République a présenté la
semaine dernière à Saintes cette réforme
elle vise très concrètement à lutter
contre le décrochage scolaire trop
fréquent en lycée professionnel n'ont
pas du fait des lycées professionnels et
des personnels éducatifs je tiens à le
redire parce que c'est fragilité là
existait déjà auparavant c'est pourquoi
nous allons travailler et nous avons
déjà travaillé dès le primaire le
collège également pour travailler sur le
décrochage scolaire pour favoriser
l'insertion professionnelle et la
poursuite d'études réussie de ces jeunes
et valoriser ses filières stratégiques
pour le pays c'est le changement d'image
que nous devons pouvoir opérer dans de
la voie professionnelle et ça passera
évidemment par la réussite des jeunes
mais aussi l'ouverture de filière qui
ouvre de véritable perspective
professionnelle d'avenir c'est donc pour
cela que dès cette rentrée prochaine de
nouvelles formations seront ouvertes
avec de nombreuses places dans certaines
filières qui seront ouvertes plus de
1000 places seront ouverts dès la
rentrée prochaine en ayant également un
énorme travail sur l'attractivité des
filières des métiers dès la formation
des insertion quelque part et dès la
découverte des métiers nous
travaillerons là-dessus et nous
fermerons des formations dans les taux
d'insertion ne sont pas suffisants et
nous avons des taux d'insertion qui
approchent les 10% pour certaines
formations c'est donc aussi pour chaque
territoire que des formations pourront
être ouvert ou pas lorsqu'on regarde les
10 premiers métiers recherchés c'est les
7 premiers au moins concernent tous les
territoires nous travaillerons là-dessus
un milliard d'euros investi en plus
chaque année
la parole est à Monsieur Fabien Roussel
pour le groupe GDR madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre de l'Industrie
j'étais ce matin avec une délégation
d'élus communiste à Trith-Saint-Léger à
la rencontre des salariés de valdune
menacés par le départ de son principal
actionnaire le chinois ma style valdune
avec son site de tri Saint Léger et sa
forge a le frein Cook et la seule
l'unique entreprise française a réalisé
des roues des axes des essieux pour
faire rouler nos trains nos métros nos
tramway c'est la seule en France le
savoir-faire de ces 346 salariés est
unique nous avons besoin de ces deux
sites Trith-Saint-Léger et le frein Cook
pour livrer le matériel nécessaire à nos
régions via Alstom et à nos entreprises
publiques que sont la SNCF et la RATP
cette usine a été livrée il y a des
années à des actionnaires étrangers ils
s'en vont donc acte c'est l'occasion de
reprendre la main sur un outil
stratégique indispensable à notre
filière industrielle comme à la
transition écologique d'abord il revient
à la SNCF de faire travailler la France
plutôt que d'autres pays la SNCF
commandée encore il y a 10 ans 45000
roues par an et 5000 essieux à valdune
l'année dernière ce chiffre est tombé à
3500 roues par an et trois essieux la
SNCF la RATP Alstom qui vivent largement
grâce à l'argent public doivent
s'engager à travailler d'abord avec
valdune plutôt que de profiter avec
cynisme de la concurrence libre et non
faussée car une heure de travail qui
part en Chine ou à l'étranger c'est une
heure de chômage que nous payons ici en
France et il faut arrêter avec ça c'est
ça qui tue notre industrie et nos
emplois pour rendre compétitif valdune
il faut aussi investir dans sa forge et
lui garantir du gaz et de l'électricité
pas cher et décarbonée et c'est possible
il faut régler ce problème énergétique
monsieur le ministre vous travaillez un
plan en faveur de l'industrie verte et
bien valtunes doit en faire partie la
BPI doit pouvoir rentrer rapidement dans
la capitale de l'entreprise pour lui
garantir son avenir et attirer des
investisseurs des industriels et non des
prédateurs financiers je vous remercie
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Roland Lescure ministre délégué
chargé de l'Industrie merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député de famille
Roussel d'abord j'aimerais reconnaître
que contrairement à d'autres qui
découvre valdune quand elle fait la Une
vous êtes déjà depuis nombreuses
semaines aux côtés des salariés les 130
qui travaillent à l'offrinckouck et les
250 attrist-saint-léger puisque mauvais
déjà alerté sur cette situation je tiens
à le souligner situation pas facile
parce que vous l'avez dit MH style
depuis racheté par baostyle grande
entreprise publique chinoise qui est en
détenu par l'État n'a pas le droit
d'aider des entreprises à
l'international avait acheté valdune en
espérant pouvoir vendre des roues en
Chine
ça n'a pas été possible on a du coup
aujourd'hui une entreprise qui est en
surcapacité qui ne vend des roues
aujourd'hui qu'en France et vous l'avez
dit insuffisamment à partir de là il
faut qu'on regarde de très près la
situation avec d'abord l'actionnaire et
la direction pour qu'un court terme ça
va être ma priorité des jours et des
semaines qui viennent on puisse
continuer l'activité sur le site parce
qu'aujourd'hui vous le savez l'acier qui
sert pour faire les roues de valdune il
vient de Chine et il y a un risque
d'arrêt de l'approvisionnement ça va
être ma priorité à très court terme et
du côté de l'approvisionnement d'énergie
également vous l'avez dit l'énergie de
valdune vient aujourd'hui daskoval le
voisin on a besoin de s'assurer que ce
soit pas trop cher un moyen terme on va
devoir trouver un repreneur avec vous
l'avez dit un outil de travail qui est
obsolète la forge elle a plus de 50 ans
on a des besoins d'investissement fort
on a aussi besoin de retrouver de la
compétitivité sur le site qui fabrique
les roues j'ai bien peur qu'une solution
du type BPI ne soit pas suffisante on va
pas nationaliser la production de rue ou
de roues pardon en France on retrouver
un investisseur stratégique pas un
investisseur financier vous l'avez dit
qui va nous permettre de redresser tout
ou partie de l'activité en attendant
évidemment on suit de très près la
situation y compris celles des salariés
qui travaillent encore pour cette
entreprise merci je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre la parole est à
Madame Virginie dubulaire pour le couple
républicain merci madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre des Armées le 4 avril dernier
vous avez présenté la loi de
programmation militaire pour 2024 2030
ce texte qui fixe les orientations de
notre politique de défense pour les 7
prochaines années consacre un budget de
413 milliards d'euros à nos armées soit
2,1% du PIB cet effort budgétaire
important n'est pas un luxe mais un
impératif au regard de la dégradation du
contexte géopolitique marqué par la
guerre en Ukraine ainsi que par
l'émergence de nouvelles menaces
terrorisme notamment en Afrique
prolifération nucléaire de la Corée du
Nord et de l'Iran guerre sous voutte
nucléaire de la Russie menace hybride en
particulier dans les votre mère à cette
instabilité géopolitique s'ajoutent des
sauts technologiques continuent dans les
domaines de la robotique des drones et
bientôt de la technologie quantique ou
de l'intelligence artificielle dans ce
monde chaque jour plus dangereux la
guerre en Ukraine a montré que la
manière de faire la guerre évolue elle
aussi outre les champs de conflictualité
traditionnelle RTR maire il faut
désormais ajouter l'espace et les fonds
marins mais aussi les champs immatériels
tels que le cyberespace ou les fake news
la France ne peut pas ignorer ses
nouveaux enjeux géostratégiques si elle
veut assurer ses missions prioritaires
en matière de défense certes la LPM
consacre des moyens budgétaires
importants pour l'adaptation de nos
armées aux enjeux actuels notamment en
matière technologiques 4 milliards sont
dédiés aussi Bert 6 milliards à l'espace
8 milliards au numérique et 10 milliards
à l'innovation mais on peut toutefois
regretter que ces investissements ne
soient pas au niveau de se réaliser par
le Royaume-Uni ou l'Allemagne et que
surtout ces efforts soient prévus après
le quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron alors
qu'il faudrait prévoir une montée en
puissance dès 2025 sans compter monsieur
le ministre que la politique de défense
est avant tout une affaire humaine
l'armée a besoin d'hommes et de femmes
prêts à s'engager pour leur pays alors
Monsieur le Ministre pourriez-vous nous
indiquer comment vous comptez mettre les
ressources humaines des armées en
cohérence avec les ambitions
stratégiques de la LPM je vous remercie
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Patricia mirales secrétaire d'État
chargé des anciens combattants et de la
mémoire
merci et madame la présidente madame la
députée du pimuler j'excuse Sébastien
Lecornu ministre des armées qui est
actuellement en train de suivre la
situation en Guyane les cybers attaquent
auxquels notre pays est confronté sont
plus nombreuses depuis quelques mois des
actions cybercriminelles par exemple
contre l'hôpital de Corbeil-Essonnes des
actions de groupe de hackers comme le
site du Sénat la semaine dernière des
actions plus stratégiques provenant
d’état de sabotage de renseignements
sachez que la France prend déjà la
menace cyber très au sérieux les agents
de Lancy qui dépendent de la première
ministre sont les pompiers cyber de la
France nous renforcerons leur
prérogative dans la prochaine loi de
programmation militaire d'autres
ministères sont également impliqués
notamment Bercy pardon
notamment Bercy le ministère de la
Justice le ministère de l'Intérieur et
le Quai d'Orsay quant à lui le ministère
des armées développe ses capacités cyber
pour garantir les opérations militaires
notamment la dissuasion pour en
continuer malgré d'éventuelles à taxes
cyber le ministère des armées contribue
aussi à la cyberdéfense de la nation
même si vous me permettez de rester
discrète à ce sujet nos services de
renseignement participent à l'imputation
d'attaque la DGA met à disposition son
centre d'expertise pour l'analyse des
logiciels my vélo le ministère est en
charge de la réponse cyber à une attaque
face à l'augmentation des menaces nous
souhaitons que la France reste dans le
match des grandes nations du cyber du
cyber pour développer notre
capacité de détection sur nos systèmes
et nos moyens de riposte notamment en
utilisant l'intelligence artificielle et
le cantique nous proposons dans la LPM
de mettre en place une filière
excellence cyber autour de l'école
polytechnique aussi nous souhaitons
doubler la réserve cyber qui est un pont
entre les entreprises et l'État c'est un
effort auquel toute la nation doit se
préparer le ministère des armées prendra
sa part la LPM sera débattu tout à
l'heure en commission et nous y
répondrons je vous remercie madame la
ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Paul André
Colombani pour le groupe yote merci
madame la présidente monsieur le garde
des sceaux chers collègues
l'infiltration de nos sociétés par les
réseaux sous criminels dépassent toutes
les fictions cette citation pourrait
être l'accroche d'une série policière il
en est pourtant rien
ces mots se sont se prononcés récemment
par l'orbecueo procureur de Paris à la
tête de la juridiction nationale chargée
de la lutte contre la criminalité
organisée elle décrit l'essor
vertigineux du crime organisé en Europe
dépassant aujourd'hui toute imagination
la situation est pour le moins
inquiétante et les groupes mafieux sont
dittels aujourd'hui sans limite en
termes de financement de projection
géographique et de recours à la violence
des pays frontaliers comme les Pays-Bas
ou la Belgique constate avec impuissance
l'emprise grandissante de la macromafia
qui menace sérieusement leur
fonctionnement démocratique la
Commission européenne s'est emparée du
sujet et annonce vouloir légiférer en
matière de lutte contre le crime
organisé la France elle-même n'est
évidemment pas épargnée par les
phénomènes mafieux loin sans faux
face à ce constat monsieur le garde des
sceaux vous l'avez dit avec lucidité
dans une interview accordée aux
Parisiens la semaine dernière il n'est
désormais plus possible de fermer les
yeux à ce sujet je vous avais interpellé
sur la mise en place de trois mesures
également réclamées par les collectifs
antimafia premièrement la nécessité le
nécessaire évolution du statut du
repenti deuxièmement la confiscation
systématique des avoirs criminels
faisant d'ailleurs l'objet d'une PPL
porté bon par mon collègue Jean-Luc
verseman qui a fourni un travail
remarquable enfin une évolution
législative inspirée des normes ayant
déjà fait leurs preuves en Italie et
dans le cadre du dispositif qui protège
les marchés publics du tunnel Lyon-Turin
aussi êtes-vous prêt monsieur le garde
des sceaux à placer ces mesures au cœur
de votre stratégie de lutte contre la
mafia et à faire de celle-ci une grande
priorité je vous remercie
j'ai mon cher collègue la parole est à
Éric Dupond-Moretti garde des sceaux
ministre de la justice merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député Colombani
votre question est une question
intéressante durant trop longtemps nous
avons négligé ces phénomènes criminels
et vous avez rappelé à juste titre ce
que des organisations criminelles ont
été capables de faire en Belgique
récemment et au Pays-Bas la réponse elle
est triple si j'ose dire d'abord une
réponse européenne n'en déplaise aux
eurosceptiques
enquête commune
euro juste y evidence sur lequel nous
avons travaillé et qu'il me soit permis
de dire que récemment les enquêtes
communes ont permis de démanteler les
deux plus gros trafic de drogue de
l'histoire deuxième volet vous avez 1000
fois raison il faut taper au
portefeuille la confiscation des avoir
criminels la grâce il travaille nous
avons multiplié les antennes à Grasse
récemment nous sommes allés avec
Gabriel Attal faire une vente qui nous a
rapporté
beaucoup
d'argent et nous avons la possibilité
aujourd'hui vous le savez vous le savez
de confisquer des immeubles et de les
distribuer à des associations
caritatives je veux remercier
chaleureusement le député varsmann avec
lesquels nous travaillons en permanence
troisièmement le statut du repenti je
suis allé il y a une dizaine de jours en
Italie pour m'inspirer de ce qu'ils font
parce qu'ils connaissent hélas depuis
très longtemps les phénomènes mafieux je
veux remercier à cet instant précis
Sacha Oullier président de la commission
des lois mais également le président
Marc Angeli avec lequel nous avons
commencé à travailler et je vous annonce
que d'ici la fin de l'année un texte
sera prêt sur cette question des
repentis je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre
la parole est à monsieur Alexandre Roy
pour le coup Renaissance
merci Madame madame la Présidente
Monsieur le monsieur le ministre de la
transition écologique un parc immobilier
zéro émission d'ici 2050 c'est
l'ambition qui a fixé le Parlement
européen il y a quelques semaines à
Strasbourg en cette Journée de l'Europe
qui nous est si cher en tout cas à
beaucoup d'entre nous c'est sur cet
objectif triplement essentiel que je
veux insister monsieur le ministre
essentiel parce que vital pour notre
planète le bâtiment terre c'est 36% des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre de
l'Union européenne et sensuelle ensuite
pour le portefeuille des Françaises et
des Françaises 1 € sur 20 dépensé par
nos concitoyens et dépensé pour se
chauffer primordial aussi monsieur le
ministre pour notre souveraineté
nationale et européenne pour réduire nos
dépendances énergétiques qui constituent
une faiblesse collective majeure dans un
monde toujours plus important
monsieur le ministre cette majorité
depuis plus de 6 ans c'est pleinement
engagé pour réaliser la décarbonate la
décarbonation de notre parc immobilier
je pense aux lois élan je pense à la loi
climat et résilience ce matin j'étais à
vos côtés en tant que président de la
commission de surveillance de la Caisse
des Dépôts avec notre collègue Thomas
Cazenave président de la Délégation aux
collectivités territoriales pour le
lancement d'un vaste chantier national
celui de la rénovation thermique de
toutes les écoles du pays de quoi
parlons-nous de 12 millions d'écoliers
de collégiens de lycéens de 50000 écoles
de collèges de lycée de la France
partout aux cycoins de l'Hexagone de la
moitié du bâtiment terre public monsieur
le ministre à l'image des immenses
chantées du 19e siècle monsieur le
ministre de Guizot et de ferry ce grand
projet de restauration écologique de nos
écoles doit fédérer toutes les forces
vives de notre pays autour de cette
ambition alliant transition écologique
souveraineté énergétique vertu
pédagogique
et bon sens financier alors Monsieur le
Ministre pouvez-vous ici devant la
représentation nationale nous détailler
comment avec les collectivités
territoriales vous entendez garantir à
nos petits-enfants réels ou
hypothétiques que leur école répondra à
l'objectif européen ou qu'elle se situe
sur le territoire national merci
beaucoup mon cher collègue la parole est
à Monsieur Christophe Béchu ministre de
la transition écologique et de la
cohésion des territoires
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
alroyd
vous avez évoqué cette réunion de
travail de ce matin qui a permis à
l'ensemble des forces vives de se
retrouver autour de ce grand chantier
premier par le Président de la
République rappelait le 24 avril dernier
et confié à la première ministre comme
étant une des briques essentielles de la
planification écologique qu'elle corde
130 millions de mètres carrés voilà la
somme du bâti scolaire dans notre pays
et ça donne une idée des enjeux et je
dirais même du triple en jeu qui a
derrière un enjeu climatique pour
diminuer nos émissions de gaz à effet de
serre un enjeu budgétaire pour faire en
sorte que les collectivités puissent
maîtriser l'évolution de leur facture
énergétique compte tenu des tendances
que nous connaissons et enfin je dirais
un enjeu de transmission
parce que quand on apprend dans des
bâtiments qui sont trop chauds ou trop
froids la qualité de la transmission
pédagogique ne se passe pas dans les
mêmes conditions et aider nos
enseignants et des nos professeurs dans
la continuité de ce que Papen Diagne et
Carole Grandjean font c'est évidemment
faire en sorte qu'il y a un cadre qui
permette de le faire 5 outils à
disposition des collectivités
territoriales d'abord laissez de eux
dans le cadre du programme acté+ on
parle de 220 millions d'euros ensuite le
fond chaleur 520 millions le fond vert
qui est la nouveauté pour l'année de
milliards et j'ai le plaisir de vous
indiquer que sur les 1300 premiers
lauréats 200 sont des bâtiments
scolaires qui vont bénéficier de
rénovation ensuite deux nouvelles
d'abord le tiers financement la PPL
Cazenave voté à l'unanimité à
l'Assemblée au Sénat aujourd'hui même
les décrets d'application seront soumis
à consultation enfin ce que la Caisse
des dépôts est consignation sous votre
surveillance monsieur le Président lance
avec edu-rénov 10 000 écoles que nous
allons pouvoir initier d'ici la fin du
quinquennat ça a été au coeur de la
réunion de ce matin ça va maintenant se
décliner avec toutes les associations
d'élus mi-mai puis en faisant en sorte
de revenir vers tous les maires de
France avec une communication qui sera
ciblée avant le début de l'été pour leur
préciser les moyens de relever ensemble
ce chantier du siècle pour le climat
pour le budget et pour nos enfants je
vous remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Madame Marianne Maximy
pour la France insoumise
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Intérieur hier nous
commémorions la victoire des alliés sur
la barbarie nazie samedi des
nostalgiques des Jeunesses hitlériennes
défilaient bien tranquillement dans les
rues de Paris accompagnée de deux
proches de Madame Le Pen depuis silence
sur les bancs des ministres vous qui
êtes si prompte à condamner et interdire
votre silence monsieur le ministre
veut-il donc appauvassion alors que des
dizaines d'événements contre la réforme
des retraites sont régulièrement
interdits cette manifestation était
autorisée par la préfecture qui a
considéré qu'il n'y avait pas de risque
de troubles de l'ordre public comment le
croire dans un contexte où les
agressions d'extrême droite se
multiplient comme il y a quelques jours
ou des néonazis se rendant à la finale
de la Coupe de France sont agressés des
passants simplement parce qu'il n'était
pas blanc et on tabassé un de nos
assistants parlementaires qui essayaient
de filmer ces exactions et je vous le
confirme monsieur le ministre il a bien
déposé plainte
comment le savoir quand la préfecture
dans un arrêté du 5 mai à autorisé
l'emploi de drone pour surveiller
justement cette manifestation pour
prévenir les risques d'atteinte à
l'ordre public la préfecture est de
mauvaise foi quand elle se cache
derrière le risque d'annulation d'une
interdiction par le tribunal
administratif de nombreuses
interdictions de manifestations contre
la réforme des retraites ont déjà été
cassées par la justice sans que cela
vous empêche de continuer d'en prendre
pourquoi ce deux poids de mesure
doit-on comprendre que les casseroles
sont plus dangereuses pour l'ordre
public que les fascistes violents
c'est malheureusement le message que
vous envoyez quand vous permettez que le
président fasse vider les Champs-Élysées
pour défiler à la bruit du bruit des
casseroles et qu'on autorise le bruit
des bottes à retentir dans nos rues
grâce à la complicité du silence des
pantoufles du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre cessez de
stigmatiser le peuple qui loute qui
lutte voyait la violence de l'extrême
droite qui s'organise sous votre nez
quand allez-vous agir
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Sonia baquet
secrétaire d'État à la citoyenneté
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
maximie oui la première ministre l'a dit
et le ministre l'intérieur de l'a dit
les images que nous avons vu samedi sont
insupportables mais oui la boussole du
ministère de l'intérieur c'est le
respect de l'État de droit et des
décisions de justice le respect de
l'État droit c'est de décider sur la
base de la loi et des décisions de
justice si une manifestation peut se
tenir ou pas le respect de l'État de
droit c'est concernant l'ultra droite
une main qui n'a pas tremblée avec la
dissolution par le ministre de
l'Intérieur de 12 groupus groupuscules
d'ultra-droite depuis 2017 le respect de
l'État droit c'est il y a quelques mois
la dissolution des zoaves de Paris qui
organisaient des actions racistes
antisémites contre les homosexuels
contre les transsexuels
le respect de l'État droit c'est
l'interdiction par les préfets de
plusieurs manifestations d'ultra-droite
ces derniers mois à Montpellier à Paris
à Lyon le respect de l'État droit c'est
l'enquête qui est en cours sur
l'agression dont a été victime votre
collaborateur parlementaire et le
respect de l'État droit c'est la
décision rendue publique il y a quelques
instants par le par Gérald Darmanin
d'interdire toutes les manifestations
d'ultra-droite parce que le respect de
l'État de droit c'est aussi la sanction
systématique et sans concession de tous
les propos et de toutes les actions à
caractère raciste ou antisémites et
antisémite
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Laurent
Croisier pour le groupe démocrate oui
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues
électricien menuisier agent de sécurité
Masson boulanger vendeur conducteur
d'engins cuisinier comptable et
soignants métiers de la petite enfance
ou de l'aide à la personne au masculin
comme au féminin ces métiers ont en
commun de travailler au quotidien auprès
des Français et pour beaucoup d'entre
eux de s'apprendre en lycée
professionnel
les députés démocrates considèrent que
la réforme du lycée professionnel
présenté jeudi dernier par le Président
de la République est un enjeu majeur
pour l'avenir de notre jeunesse et un
défi de ce quinquennat
tout d'abord parce que le lycée
professionnel accueille un lycéen sur
trois ensuite parce qu'il accueille
majoritairement des élèves qui cumulent
les vulnérabilités scolaires ou sociales
et enfin parce qu'il est malheureusement
encore aujourd'hui rarement un choix
alors qu'il forme des femmes et des
hommes qui seront les faiseurs de nos
grandes transitions les bâtisseurs des
futurs grandes innovations et les
acteurs de l'accompagnement humain et
social qui nous est cher pour toutes ces
raisons le groupe démocrate est très
exigeant sur l'ambition de la réforme le
lycée professionnel se doit d'être une
voie de réussite professionnelle une
voix de réussite personnelle une filière
d'excellence la réforme doit porter en
elle la promesse républicaine de
l'ascenseur social aujourd'hui seul un
lycéen sur deux paga parvient à l'emploi
une année après l'obtention de son
diplôme madame la chargé de
l'enseignement et de la formation
professionnelle nous devons à ces jeunes
un parcours vers la réussite nous leur
devons l'égalité des chances l'objectif
est de parvenir à 100% d'insertion
professionnelle est un objectif
ambitieux comment entendez-vous
favoriser la réussite professionnelle en
atténuant les inégalités sociales qui
persistent comment tendez-vous agir
contre le décrochage scolaire qui est un
sujet clé en résumé madame la ministre
comment comptez-vous réaffirmer le lycée
professionnel dans sa mission
d'ascenseur social merci beaucoup mon
cher collègue la parole est à madame
Carole Grandjean ministre délégué de
l'enseignement et de la formation
professionnelle merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député Croisier je
sais votre engagement sur ce sujet vous
pouvez compter sur notre engagement
principal sur la question de la lutte
contre le décrochage scolaire c'est un
enjeu majeur de cette réforme vous
l'avez rappelé je tiens à le redire il y
a 10 fois plus de chances de décrocher
pour un élève venant du lycée
professionnel et deux tiers des
décrocheurs viennent de la voie
professionnelle c'est un enjeu majeur
pour le Lycée professionnel non pas du
fait encore une fois des enseignants et
de ses équipes pédagogiques mais du fait
de nombreuses fragilités du système vous
l'avez rappelé orientation subie plus
faible au niveau scolaire difficulté
diverses totalement sociale celle du
handicap ou de la langue française
jeunesse des élèves toutes ces
fragilités là font que si nous
n'agissons pas ces élèves ne vont pas
jusqu'au bout du parcours si pendant le
quinquennat précédent nous avons
travaillé sur l'école primaire si
aujourd'hui papendiaye accompagne une
réforme du collège pour pouvoir
accompagner ces fragilités scolaires
nous devons faire du lycée professionnel
également à un acteur engagé pour lutter
contre ce décrochage ça passera par des
moyens inédits mis sur le lycée
professionnel puis d'un milliard d'euros
par an supplémentaires mis pour le Lycée
professionnel pour faire plus de petits
groupes pour accompagner mieux les
fragilités scolaires pour faire aussi
plus d'options accompagner des
ouvertures culturelles accomp diagnostic
de l'estime de soi de la confiance en
soi accompagné aussi des stages et
l'insertion professionnelle et notamment
le mentorat avec un centre de
partenaires qui vont nous accompagner
pour mieux les préparer et puis
organiser la lutte contre décrochage
avec les partenaires école de la
deuxième chance EPIDE Mission Locale
tout ce réseau de partenaires qui très
tôt peuvent venir nous aider à lutter
contre le décrochages c'est aussi
travailler sur les stages la qualité des
stages le réseau de d'entreprises pour
ceux qui n'en ont pas travaillé sur
cette recherche d'entreprise dans
lesquelles ces jeunes iront faire des
stages et se faire des expériences
professionnelles et puis en parallèle de
tout cela c'est travailler sur la
découverte des métiers travailler sur
l'orientation choisie travailler
également sur l'attractivité des métiers
et France 2030 nous permettra d'investir
pour mettre en visibilité des filières
et enfin parce que le pacte du lycée
professionnel est très orienté sur cet
objectif nous n'allons d'acheter aucun
jeune ni avant le baccalauréat
professionnel ou cap n'y a après le
diplôme car nous devons faire que chacun
ait une solution je vous remercie merci
beaucoup
la parole est à Madame Valérie Bazin
malgratte pour le groupe les
républicains
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le garde des sceaux monsieur le
ministre je fais suite aux annonces du
projet de loi d'orientation et de
programmation de la justice que vous
avez présenté en Conseil des ministres
la semaine dernière
l'embauche de 10000 personnes dont 1500
magistrats et 1500 greffiers est une
bonne nouvelle sur le papier qui tend un
rassurer et a donné enfin les moyens à
notre justice c'est un bon début mais
cela est encore bien insuffisant quand
on sait que pour un magistrat il
faudrait au bas mot deux ou trois
greffiers pour fluidifier son travail je
m'en suis rendu compte lors d'une visite
au tribunal judiciaire de Troyes pas
plus tard que la semaine dernière ou
plusieurs juridictions croulent sous les
stocks insurmontables d'affaires à gérer
faute de personnel insuffisant pour
traiter tous ces dossiers dans un délai
raisonnable les Français attendent de
vous des réponses et des actes pour
désengorger nos tribunaux cela provoque
un ressenti négatif dans la population
pouvant la conduire à un vote populiste
vous le savez monsieur le garde des
sceaux je défends mon tribunal et je
plaide pour son bon fonctionnement comme
pour tous les tribunaux de France vous
le savez aussi l'ouverture prochaine de
la maison d'arrêt de troix-laaux
ouverture nécessaire pour notre
territoire mais aussi pour désengorger
les prisons parisiennes et
d'Île-de-France va augmenter l'activité
du tribunal de 3 je vous ai déjà
sollicité plusieurs fois afin de pouvoir
les postes vacants voir augmenter les
effectifs notamment des magistrats et
des greffiers alors dès aujourd'hui afin
de permettre à nos magistrats du siège
de gagner du temps et de l'efficacité il
y a une mesure que vous pourriez mettre
en oeuvre immédiatement c'est prendre un
décret pour autoriser la signature
électronique au civile comme il existe
au pénal ce qui simplifiera et
soulagerait les magistrats dans leur
mission de contentieux de soins
psychiatriques ou pour le contrôle des
mesures d'isolement et de contention
alors monsieur le garde des sceaux qu'en
prendrez-vous ce décret je vous remercie
je vous remercie ma chère collègues la
parole est à Éric Dupond-Moretti garde
des sceaux ministres de régime
la députée Valérie Bazin Malgras d'abord
je vous remercie de me poser cette
question et je voudrais dire ou plus
exactement redire car vous avez d'ores
et déjà dit les choses que d'abord il y
avait une loi de programmation merci de
souligner qu'elle va dans le bon sens si
je puis me permettre magistrat 1500
greffier 1500 mais également les
attachés de justice en nombre pour aider
nos juridictions et ensuite les moyens
évidemment
réglementaires si j'ose dire je veux
mettre en place l'amiable en matière
civile et puis enfin troisième volet le
numérique alors vous proposez le décret
qui pourrait être signé tout de suite
sur la signature électronique je
voudrais vous dire que vous allez un
tout petit peu vite parce qu'il faut
d'abord que l'on est un outil pour
conserver de façon électronique les
décisions rendues on le mette en place
il sera en place dès cet automne madame
la députée et si votre juridiction celle
que qui vous est si chère et qui est si
cher à Monsieur Barouin le tribunal
judiciaire de 3 souhaite expérimenter
cet outil c'est d'accord qu'il me le
fasse savoir et je pense qu'ils ont vous
une interlocutrice de qualité comme on
le fasse remonter cette juridiction
pourra expérimenter cette signature
électronique vous avez raison il faut
absolument la mettre en place dès cet
automne pas tout de suite pardon vous de
recevoir mais dès cet automne ce sera
chose faite merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre
de seconde monsieur le ministre j'ai
bien compris et mon tribunal sera
candidat j'en suis certaine merci Merci
beaucoup ma chère collègues la parole
est à Monsieur Jean-Claude Rault pour le
coupé écologiste
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre je me garderai bien de
critiquer l'incriticable réforme du
lycée professionnel annoncé à Saintes
déjà un signe en soi aussi je me
contenterai de dire que nous avons de la
chance d'avoir un président qui promet
l'excellence rien de moins au plus des
favorisé sur le plan scolaire un
président qui a changé de méthode après
l'absence totale d'écoute et le mépris
la concertation mais sont des syndicats
un peu ou très oubliés et des
professionnels un peu aidés voir
remplacer par une start-up et
rendez-vous compte de la chance que nous
avons un milliard d'euros pour la voix
professionnelle qu'on pourrait presque
appeler l'avoir royale et il va payer
les élèves d'un euro 43 2,86 € de
l'heure mais ce sera toujours bon à
prendre pour faire adhérer les familles
les plus pauvres à la vision
présidentielle
je vous demande quand même dites moi que
cette grande cause nationale n'est pas
en fin de compte qu'une
instrumentalisation de l'enseignement
professionnel que nous récusons de
toutes nos forces je vous remercie mon
cher collègue la parole est à madame
Carole Grandjean ministre délégué chargé
de l'enseignement et de la formation
professionnelle merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député Jean-Claude
Drot n'est-ce pas vos propres éléments
de langage il y a quelques semaines
lorsque vous annonciez le fait qu'il n'y
avait aucune annonce budgétaire qui
accompagnaient les évolutions de la
carte des formations et bien c'est tout
l'inverse monsieur le député puisque
c'est plus d'un milliard d'euros chaque
année supplémentaire qui vont être
investis dans le lycée professionnel
pour accompagner cette préparation et
cette acquisition des compétences qui
permettront à ces élèves et à ce pays de
relever les grands défis de la nation
nous accompagnerons aussi cette carte de
tolérance formation des formations
pardon par ce plan France 2030 avec plus
de 2,5 milliards d'euros consacré au
plateau technique consacré aux
formations des enseignants consacré
également à la meilleure attractivité
des filières d'avenir alors vous le
voyez si vos éléments de langage sont
bloqués sur sur ces sujets pour notre
part nous avançons par ailleurs dans
votre communiqué vous indiquez aussi
monsieur le député dans vos éléments de
langage une pseudo concertation je
dirais gare au pseudo vérité car nous
avons eu de cesse d'organiser ses
concertations par une large consultation
de l'ensemble des partis prenantes dès
la rentrée 2022 constitué de professeurs
d'élèves de parents d'élèves de
représentants d'établissements et des
académies des partenaires sociaux des
représentants des régions et des
associations c'est plus de 160 personnes
qui ont participé à ces groupes de
travail durant trois mois et mis 200
propositions ce sont également des
débats l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat
qui ont eu lieu et c'est évidemment des
rendez-vous réguliers avec les
partenaires sociologues voyez vous le
voyez monsieur le député cette réforme
maladie méthode et ambition nous le
devons laisser un professionnel nous
l'amènerons jusqu'au bout pour favoriser
de meilleures conditions de travail pour
les personnels éducatifs et une
meilleure réussite pour les jeunes je
vous remercie je vous remercie madame la
ministre la parole
à Monsieur Henry alphonari pour le
groupe horizon merci madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre de la
transition écologique et la cohésion des
territoires grâce à l'action du
Gouvernement et au travail effectué par
la majorité présidentielle nous avons
initié ensemble des politiques
ambitieuses en matière de transition
énergétique et écologique l'État
s'engage financièrement auprès des
Français des entreprises et des
collectivités pour être à la hauteur de
ses ambitions néanmoins comme plusieurs
de mes collègues j'ai pu constater des
difficultés d'application sur le terrain
des décisions prises au niveau national
notamment dû aux instructions des
différents services déconcentrés de
l'État
monsieur le ministre vous avez défendu
et porté la création d'un fond vert pour
accompagner nos collectivités dans leurs
investissements notamment ceux
concernant les bâtiments publics ces
investissements sont essentiels à
l'heure où nous devons limiter nos
émissions et montrer l'exemple mais
aussi limiter les factures énergétiques
afin de pouvoir garantir les services
publics que les collectivités rendent à
nos concitoyens je vais citer l'exemple
d'une commune qui a un projet de
chaufferie biomasse ce projet était
parfaitement éligible à des fonds des
cils des instructions ont été données
pour réorienter ce type de projet vers
le fond vert or pour être éligible au
fond vert il faut réunir au moins trois
critères et comme l'isolation du
bâtiment concerné avait été bien faite
le projet n'en réunit que deux ainsi il
est recalé alors même qu'il ferait
économiser plus de 60% de consommation
et donc d'économies je vous pourrez vous
parler problème similaires sur les
permis de construire sur les EnR mais
aussi sur les minimis qui limitent le
déploiement de projets dont nous avons
besoin
comment Monsieur le Ministre pouvez-vous
intervenir pour que ce bel objet
qu'elles font vert ne soit pas abîmé par
des lourdeurs lourdeurs administratives
qui nous empêcheront de réaliser nos
objectifs
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
alphari
ce fond vert aujourd'hui les victimes de
son succès 10000 476 c'est le chiffre à
hier matin du nombre de dossiers déposés
pour bénéficier de ces crédits ça
représente une somme de 3,7 milliards
d'euros de demande qui générait 16
milliards d'euros de travaux
on est au début du processus
le dépôt des dossiers a commencé le 27
janvier et à la minute je vous parle
nous n'avons que 1527 lauréats il y a
donc que 200 millions d'euros qui ont
été attribués le reste est en train de
s'examiner
comme n'importe quel dispositif nouveau
il faut évidemment trouver le temps et
trouver la bonne mécanique pour que ça
fonctionne et il faut bien comprendre
que dans un premier temps le fond vert
c'est autant à lui seul que la décile et
la DETR réunis donc ça double les
enveloppes d'investissement il y a des
pré-arbitrage qui parfois ont conduit à
fléchir vers de la desciles ou du faire
du fond vert mais à la fin puisque
chaque département connaît la somme qui
lui attribuait je ne doute pas que dans
les prochaines semaines on fera d'abord
véritablement en sorte de consommer
l'enveloppe disponible mais de les
fléchir sur les projets qui sont
efficaces et il y en a dans tous les
territoires l'Indre-et-Loire chez vous
c'est 91 le Pas-de-Calais c'est 318 la
Martinique c'est 63 et je pourrais
continuer de cette manière le 24 mai
nous aurons la première réunion de
retour d'expérience pour regarder sous
le couvert de mon administration ce que
nous pouvons encore simplifier depuis le
début en refusant les appels à projets
et les appels à manifestation d'intérêt
et en confiant les crédits à la main des
préfets pour que ce soit souple et
déconcentré on a précisément voulu
éviter lourdeur je vous assure qu'on va
dans le détail regardez comment
précisément on respecte à la fois la
philosophie et les objectifs mais d'ores
et déjà cet outil de territorialisation
de la planification écologique montre
bien que quand on accompagne les élus
locaux pour le climat pour la
biodiversité les résultats sont au
rendez-vous et l'annonce faite par la
première mise de dispositif de sa
pérennisation le 11 avril dernier va
nous permettre au delà de l'année 2023
de regarder comment l'édition 2024
pourra nous permettre d'avoir tous les
avantages sans les quelques
inconvénients que nous avons pour le
moment
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Lionel Tivoli pour
le rassemblement national oui madame la
Présidente mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à la ministre de
l'Enseignement supérieur et de la
Recherche madame Sylvie Retailleau suite
à la crise de la covid 19 et maintenant
l'hyperinflation qui grève sérieusement
le pouvoir d'achat des Français les
conditions de vie de nos étudiants se
sont largement dégradées chaque semaine
ce sont des fils d'étudiants qui se
forment à l'entrée d'associations
caritatives pour obtenir de l'aide
alimentaire aujourd'hui vous prévoyez
une nouvelle augmentation de 5% de la
contribution vie étudiante et de campus
atteignant désormais la barre des 100
euros cette contribution est devenue de
fait un impôt étudiant qui pénalise les
étudiants et notamment ceux des classes
moyennes mais pire encore la CVC devenue
un outil financier au service de la
propagande wok ce sont désormais des
projets délirants qui sont financés par
le biais de la CVEC visant à endoct nos
étudiants à des idéologies dangereuses
servant l'extrême gauche or l'objectif
de la CVEC et d'améliorer les conditions
de vie des étudiants est-ce que le
financement par la CVC d'un podcast cuir
sur les questions de genre à
l'Université de Lyon où l'introduction à
l'art drague à l'Université de Bordeaux
améliore la condition de vie de nos
étudiants en quoi le financement par la
CVC du projet du mois des colonial à
l'université d'Aix-Marseille améliore la
le cadre de vie de nos étudiants ou
encore des séances de baby-foot Nogent à
l'université d'Aix-Marseille mais alors
madame la ministre avez-vous l'honnêteté
le courage de surseoir à cette
augmentation de la CVEC pour ne pas
aggraver les mauvaises conditions de vie
de nos étudiants et de surtout ne plus
vous en servir pour des délires wok je
vous remercie
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Madame Sylvie Retailleau
ministre chargé de l'enseignement
supérieur et de la Recherche merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le Député
Lionel Tivoli alors d'abord
permettez-moi de vous rappeler la
cévêque comme vous l'appelez c'est
effectivement la contribution vie
étudiante et vie de campus à la création
de la sevex est accompagnée la
suppression de plusieurs cotisations
cotisations qui étaient à l'époque la
sécurité sociale le fait FD le fsde
pardon le fond de solidarité
développement d'initiatives étudiantes
ou alors des cotisations sur la santé
étudiante pour rappel en comparaison en
2018 un étudiant hors frais de scolarité
payé 238 euros en 2023 il paiera 100
euros vous l'avez dit pour la CV c'est à
dire une économie pour chaque étudiant
non boursier de
138%. je voudrais rappeler que le
législateur l'un indexé sur l'inflation
évitant
de récolter 150 millions d'étudiants de
d'euros pardon et je voudrais préciser
que c'est 150 millions d'euros 127 ont
été reversés aux établissements et 22 et
demi au CROUS pour permettre des actions
financées et choisies par et pour les
étudiants un dernier point un rapport
pour le Parlement étant préparation et
donc vous sera très prochainement
présenté de façon complète je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
ministre allez-y mon cher collègue si je
comprends bien madame la ministre vous
rétablissez la double peine non pas pour
les délinquants mais pour les étudiants
vous braquez les étudiants non boursiers
c'est un comble et puis en plus vous les
prenez en otage de vos délires
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Jean-François lovizolo du
groupe Renaissance merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur Louise de
l'intérieur la ville de Cavaillon dans
le Vaucluse de 26000 habitants a connu
un événement dramatique la semaine
dernière sur fond de trafic de
stupéfiant vous étiez venu en août 2021
pour y créer un groupe de sécurité de
proximité conjugué aux importants moyens
mis en place par la commune vos
engagements ont permis un être utile de
la délinquance à Cavaillon 2022 comme
quoi l'insécurité n'est pas une fatalité
là où il y a une volonté il y a un
chemin l'État c'est également engagé aux
côtés de la ville en faveur d'une
rénovation urbaine à hauteur de 117
millions d'euros force de l'ordre des
rénovation urbaine sont sans doute
l'alpha et l'oméga d'une politique de la
ville ambitieuse et réussie pour autant
le Vaucluse cinquième département le
plus pauvre reste un territoire fragile
à l'image d'un règlement de compte qui a
fait deux morts à Cavaillon dans la nuit
du 1er au 2 mai illustrant la nécessité
de renforcement de moyens dès le 2 mai
au matin je vous ai contacté monsieur le
min pour demander une audience à
laquelle j'ai naturellement associé
Gérard Daudet maire de Cavaillon cette
rencontre a eu lieu vendredi matin votre
réponse est sans précédent ce sont 104
policiers supplémentaires pour assurer
la sécurité publique dans le Vaucluse
dont 60 CRS affectés de manière opérée
nos départements cela est une réponse
forte monsieur le ministre à une demande
que je vous avais faite mais la
situation du Vaucluse l'exigée ce sont
aussi plus de 40 policiers sur Avignon
Carpentras Cavaillon c'est le fruit d'un
travail collaboratif entre madame la
préfète les élus locaux Gerardo et
siciluel sergent de Rieu et votre
serviteur mais ce n'est pas fini car
demain nous allons travailler
conjointement sur le rural et le
périurbain grâce à la loi lopie ce qui
va nous permettre de permettre de
compléter le maillage territorial
notamment Vaucluse monsieur le ministre
c'est le moment de vous dire merci au
nom de l'ensemble des Vauclusiens à
l'exception des élus du rassemblement
national qui n'ont pas su se réjouir de
cette bonne nouvelle
pardon j'ai perdu mon papier
car les échecs et les immobilismes les
font prospérer nos réponses les fonds
reculés ils vont voir que pour le
vauclus cela ne fait que commencer je me
permets monsieur le ministre vous
interroger sur les conditions et les
délais du déploiement de ces renforts
exceptionnels merci
merci beaucoup mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
merci madame la Présidente
je voudrais évidemment saluer votre
action en tant que député élu dans le
Vaucluse salut Monsieur le Maire de
Cavaillon mais aussi le maire de
Carpentras et la mer d'Avignon pour le
travail quotidien qu'ils font auprès des
forces de l'ordre je le sais pour
soutenir l'action de lutte contre la
drogue puisque vous avez raison le
Vaucluse connaît un regain de trafic de
drogue depuis de nombreuses années mais
depuis la première fois en 2022 avec les
services du ministre de la Justice nous
faisons reculer ce trafic 52 garde à vue
19 kg de cannabis saisie 25% de points
de deal en moins il y en avait 84 en
2022 ils ne sont plus je mets des
guillemets évidemment que 63 63 de trop
monsieur le député et à Cavaillon après
9 à 10 mois de calme puisque nous avons
mis fin à des réseaux extrêmement graves
dans cette belle ville de Cavaillon le
trafic reprend et avec le beurre de
Cavaillon que j'ai reçu à votre demande
je veux ici dire et confirmer les
annonces que j'ai pu faire 43 policiers
de plus en septembre prochain à
Cavaillon à Avignon et à Carpentras et
une unité de CRS à demeure dans le
Vaucluse tout au long de l'année
c'est-à-dire qu'il y aura 200 policiers
de plus si je compte évidemment les 92
policiers supplémentaires que nous avons
mis en place depuis deux ans dans le
département du Vaucluse alors évidemment
c'est des moyens sans précédent vous
êtes le seul député non rassemblant
national du Vaucluse monsieur le député
sur cinq députés il y a un député qui
n'est pas du rassemblement national vous
avez dans la discrétion de votre mandat
à apporter des réponses fait venir des
élus qui n'étaient pas de votre
circonscription Cavaillon n'est pas dans
votre circonscription au ministère de
l'Intérieur il nous a retrouvé ensemble
avec les élus ont des réponses moi je
regrette qu'au bout deux heures de
questions il est fallu attendre que vous
soyez le seul député à me réjouir
évidemment des efforts de la police
nationale du recul du trafic de drogue
et qu'il n'y a pas eu quatre questions
des quatre autres députés qui
manifestement se désintéresse de leur
département et de se réjouissent pas
monsieur député quand retenez 200
policiers gendarmes de plus pour votre
département du Vaucluse c'est avec les
problèmes on essaie de les résoudre
d'autres vivent avec je vous remercie
madame
la parole est à Monsieur Joël abiranier
pour le groupe socialiste merci madame
la Présidente Monsieur le Ministre de
l'Éducation nationale la République non
il est pas là la République française
s'est construite et ancrée comme une
idéale d'émancipation grâce à l'école
les fameux Sartes noires de par leur
engagement au service du pays ont permis
à des générations entières d'accéder à
l'instruction cassant ainsi la prison
sociale dans laquelle certains étaient
enfermés une école forte la garantie
pour une nation d'un avenir serein or la
situation de l'école est extrêmement
inquiétante l'été dernier n’apprenait
que l'État n'arrivait pas à recruter
suffisamment de professeurs qualifiés
car le nombre de candidats était en
forte baisse depuis plusieurs années les
parents d'élèves constatent impuissants
que les professeurs absents ne sont pas
remplacés dans circonscription par
exemple dans un collège près de la
frontière espagnole un professeur
d'antenne n'a pas été remplacé pendant
près d'un an un peu plus loin la même
situation a eu lieu avec un professeur
de français en lycée alors que ses
élèves devaient passer le bac selon le
principal syndicat d'enseignant du
primaire le nombre de fermetures de
classe était mi-mars de 4944 pour
2685 couvertures soit un solde négatif
de
2259 classes nous savons qu'encore une
fois les territoires ruraux vont en
payer le plus lourd tribu il est
inacceptable de voir nos services
publics fermer les uns après les autres
et la colère qui gronde se nourrit aussi
de cet état d'abandon des territoires
ruraux par l'État la baisse de la
démographie pour expliquer les
fermetures des classes n'est pas une
explication acceptable s'il y a moins
d'élèves par classe alors l'enseignement
ne pourra en être que meilleur vous avez
annoncé une revalorisation des salaires
des enseignants dès la rentrée prochaine
cette annonce est positive car nous
avons besoin de renforcer l'attractivité
de ce métier alors monsieur le ministre
que comptez-vous faire pour assurer le
remplacement des professeurs absents
comme l'a promis le président de la
République pourquoi ne pas se saisir de
la baisse démographique pour améliorer
les conditions d'enseignement à l'école
plutôt que de fermer des classes je vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole est
à madame Carole Grandjean ministre
délégué chargé de l'enseignement et de
la formation professionnelle
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
aviranier le travail de la carte
scolaire s'exerce effectivement dans un
contexte de baisse démographique que
vous avez rappelé en moins de 10 ans la
France est passée de 830 000 à 738 000
naissances par an après une baisse
démographique de 300000 élèves sur ces 5
dernières années c'est 500 000 élèves de
moi qui sont attendus d'ici à 2027
attaché au service public de l'éducation
pour tous les territoires madame la
Première ministre a annoncé un plan pour
l'école dans les territoires ruraux et
un changement de méthode sur les
fermetures de classe avec une approche
nouvelle une approche sur trois années
en concertation avec les élèves avec les
élus pardon afin de trouver des réponses
adaptées au territoire vous le savez le
ministre a redéployé 400 postes
supplémentaires pour éviter des
fermetures de classe dans certains
territoires ruraux pour votre territoire
la fermeture envisagée n'est pas
confirmée cette décision finale sera
prise en juin pas de fermeture de classe
pour l'école courée c'est 17,5 élèves
par classe qui seront à la rentrée 2023
s'il y a une fermeture de classe C23
élèves par classe avec donc un maximum
de 24 élèves c'est conforme aux
engagements portés par le Président de
la République et de la première ministre
ainsi que du ministre c'est une
vigilance particulière pour la ruralité
qui est accordée monsieur le député vous
êtes en lien avec les interlocuteurs de
l'éducation nationale sur votre
territoire et par ailleurs vous savez
que deux nouveaux territoires éducatifs
ruraux seront ouverts à la rentrée
prochaine sur votre territoire alors
vous aurez j'en suis sûr la même énergie
pour le valoriser compter sur le nôtre
le gouvernement prend en compte la
problématique des écoles des écoles en
milieu rurales et nous prendrons toutes
les mesures nécessaires pour garantir
les conditions d'éducation de qualité
partout sur le territoire
je vous remercie madame la ministre la
séance des questions au Gouvernement est
terminée la séance est suspendue